GOOD
AFTERNOON WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND- GET STARTED IN OUR BY SIR
SHOULD BE HERE ANY MOMENT NOW.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WHEN I WELCOME YOU ALL THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES. IT'S
OUR SECOND ANNUAL EMISSIONS
UPDATE FROM THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AS MANDATE ASSEMBLY. AB ONE
NINETY SEVEN. OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. HOW TO THINK EVERYONE
WHO'S TAKEN THE TIME TO PRESENT
TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THOSE
PRESENTATIONS AND PARTICIPATE
IN THAT DISCUSSION. ALTHOUGH I
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING ON TODAY'S AGENDA- AND
HANDOUTS. WE'RE GOING TO BE-
PROVIDING SOME INFORMATIONAL
REPORT ON THE REPORTED
GREENHOUSE GASES CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC
CONTAMINANTS FROM ALL SECTORS
COVERED BY THE AIR BE SCHOOL
BEING PLAN AS A CARD BY AB ONE
NINETY SEVEN. ADDITIONALLY THIS
YEAR WILL FOCUS ON NEGATIVE GHG
EMISSIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
ARE TRACKED THE IMPACT THEY
HAVE ON STATEWIDE REDUCTION
GOALS INCLUDING I DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE NEGATIVE NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS AND ACHIEVING THEY'LL
STATEWIDE GOALS AS WELL WHILE
BE MINDFUL OUR OF OUR MOST
BURNING COMMUNITIES ALONG THE
WAY. I THINK INCLUDE WE WILL
INVITE OTHERS TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE AND SINCE THE ISSUES
RELATED TO GHG EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. ON AND SO IF YOU DO
WISH TO MAKE COMMENTS PLEASE
SIGN IN AT THE SERGEANTS TABLE.
I'M GONNA BE KEEPING TIME OUR
GOAL IS TO A GERM BY FOUR
THIRTY BUT I DON'T HAVE
ANYWHERE TO BE BUT- WE REALLY
WANT TO HAVE DINNER WITH ME
HERE I GUESS WE CAN FIGURE THAT
OUT. AND SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
IN MATH OUR CHAIR MARY NICHOLS
TO COME UP- AND GIVE HER
TESTIMONY WITH THE COVER YET
THAT WHEN MR STERN SO SUB I
KNOW HE THIS YEAR TO BE PART OF
THIS I MIGHT ENTER UP SOMEBODY
TAKE A FEW MINUTES BUT OUT TO
SEE THE AHEAD AND START SINCE
WE DON'T WANT TO BE HERE FOR
DINNER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
AS YOU STATED- THIS OF
LEGISLATION AB ONE NINETY SEVEN
REQUIRES AN ANNUAL REPORT FROM
THE CHAIR OF A R. B. AND I
THINK IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO REVIEW. WHERE WE'VE BEEN AND
WHERE WERE HAD IT SO I'LL JUST
LAUNCH RIGHT INTO IT AND- WHEN
SENATOR STERN- BECOMESIF HE
WANTS TO GO OVER ANY OF IT I'M-
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WEAR. TO DO
THAT TOO- SO. I WOULD LIKE TO.
BEGIN WITH IS. WHERE WE'VE BEEN
AND THEN TO. UP TO THE PRESENT
AND PRESENT AND MAKE SOME CALM
GOING FORWARD. AS YOU ALL KNOW
OF CARBON CREATE OVER FIFTY AGO.
WITH THE GOALS OF ATTAIN AND
MAY. HEALTHY AIR QUALITY
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC FROM
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS AND PROVIDING
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES FOR
COMPLYING WITH AIR POLLUTION-
AND LATER WE WERE GIVEN THE
TASK OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AS WELL SO. MANY WITH.
THE PARTS THAT HAVE PRODUCED OF
THE FIRST ONE THE CRITERIA. AIR
POLLUTANTS- LIST FOCUSES
PRIMARILY ON KNOCKS DOCTOR CHEN
OXIDES WHICH ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT INGREDIENT OF SMALL
THAT WE WORK ON TO TRY TO.
PREVENT OZONE FORMATION AND- OF
NOT. NOT IS ALSO A AGREE GAS
WERE SO. TURNS OUT THAT OUR
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN- MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR THAT AS
WELL. THE TERM HERE SHOWS A
PROGRESS SINCE TWO BUT REALLY
YOU COULD GO ACK TO THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND SHOW-
CONTINUE WILL- A STEADY
DECREASE DUE TO MULTIPLE
REGULATORY PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADOPTED OVER TIME- BY CAR
OF COURSE AND ALSO- BY THE US
EPA AS WELL- THE MOBILE SOURCES
ARE. RESPONSIBLE FOR BY FAR THE
LARGEST SHARE OF KNOCKS
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OF OUR- ENGINE
STANDARDS AS WELL AS OUR WORK
TO CLEAN UP FEELS AND TO- TURN
OVER THE FLEET WHICH IN RECENT
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO.
QUITE A LOT THROUGH- INCENTIVE
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED-
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS IN THIS IS A SMALL
ISHE CHART BUT IT HAS SIX OF
THE- NASTY S. OF THE- ACCESS
THAT WE DEAL WITH- AGAIN IT'S A
IT'S A GOOD STORY GOOD PICTURE.
AND IT'S IS THE REALLY. A
PRIMARILY A RESULT OF CHAIN IN
THE FUELS AND THEN THE
EMISSIONS VIA. ALTHOUGH IN I
FEEL THESE CASE WE ALSO HAVE
VERY SOURCE BUT REGULATIONS
WITH BURKE FLORA FLAME WHICH IS
USED IN THE DRY. INDUSTRY
PRIMARILY SOUTH BUT IF YOU LOOK
AT DIESEL PARTICULATE WHICH IS
BY FAR THE MOST TOXIC AND IT'S
THE ONE OVER IN THE LOWER RIGHT
HAND CORNER THAT'S PROBABLY
BEEN FOCUS OF MORE OF OUR
EFFORTS IN RECENT YEARS.
BECAUSE THE EXPOSURE IS SO WIDE
SPREAD- THROUGHOUT COMMUNITIES.
IN ALL OF THESE EFFORTS- NOW
WE'RE LOOKING TOWARDS THAT THE
OVER ARCHING IMPORTANCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SIX. HARVEST HAD
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PREPARING SCOPINGPLANS AND FOR
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING- MOST OF
THE REGULATIONS THAT COME UNDER
THAT- UNDER THE SCOPING PLANTS
AND WE'RE- VERY PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE
ACTUALLY ACHIEVED OUR TWENTY
TWENTY TARGET WHICH IS UNUSUAL
TO HAVE EXCEEDED THAT OF
EXCEEDED OUR- REQUIREMENTS-
BUT- WE WERE- HELPED. A LOT BY
OTHER FORCES PARTICULARLY I
WOULD SAY- THAT TRANSITION OF
THE UTILITIES TO CLEANER
RENEWABLE LECTRICITY THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN
WHICH IS THE ONE THAT WERE
OPERATING UNDER NOW-CONTINUES
THE APPROACH THAT WE HAD FROM
THE BEGINNING. OF USING A MIX
OF DIFFERENT MEASURES INCLUDING
DIRECT REGULATIONS INCENTIVES
AND THE MARKET BASED MECHANISM
CALLED IN TO AID AS OF PUTTING
THOSE TOGETHER TRY TO WHICH IF.
BALANCE AND TO A GOALS AT THE-
AT THE LOWEST COST FOR
CALIFORNIANS OVERALL- IN
ADDITION TO REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS SEVERAL THE
STRATEGIES THE SCOPE AND
PLANTS. ARE ALSO A LOT THIS
PART AFTER TO MEET NASH. BE AN
ERROR THE STATE STAND AT IN
WORDS FOR SEPT IN THE LOW. FUEL
STAY AND THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD. DELIVERY
CLEAN FUEL AND ENERGY AS WELL
AS THE IN CLEAN CAR PRO. WHICH
PUT MORE THAN A QUARTER MILLION
CLEAN VEHICLES ON THE ROAD THE
SUSTAINABLE ACTION PLAN THAT IS
MOVING FORWARD TOWARDS ITS ACT
IMPLEMENTATION THAT WILL RESULT
IN CLEANER SYSTEMS FOR MOVING
GOODS THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND.
OF COURSE WE HAVE THE AT FOR
EVER STATE WHY THE ECONOMY WIDE
CALF AND TRADE PROGRAM. AND
NUMBER OF THESE ARE HAVE BEEN
MODIFIED ALONG THE WAY FOR TO
TRY TO GET THE GREATEST OF. FOR
BILL. SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE
PLANS AND INVEST WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME ASSURING COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE PROGRAMS- WILL DELIVER
BENEFITS BOTH AT HOME AND-
ACROSS THE GLOBE. WE CONTINUE
TO MONITOR ALL OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS AND IN YOUR HAND
OUT YOU HAVE A LIST OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT- REPORTING AND
OVERSIGHT OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THESE CLIMATE PROGRAMS
AND TO FOLLOW WHAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING. THEY JUST WANT TO
SPEND A FEW MINUTES TALKING
ABOUT THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
BECAUSE TRANSPORTATION IS FAR
AND AWAY THE MOST IMPORTANT.
SOURCE OF BOTH GREENHOUSE GAS I
AM. MISSION SHE YOU THE SHARE
IT EACH OF THE FOR A OF THESE
TYPES OF A AND IT'S TO CONTINUE
TO BE THE BEARER WHERE WE I WAS
MOST OF A BECAUSE IT IS
DOMINATED BY- NOT ONLY OUR
PERSONAL TRANSPORTATION BUT
ALSO- THE MOVEMENT OF GOODS
INCLUDING TRUCKS BUSES FREIGHT
EQUIPMENT LOCOMOTIVES MARINE
VESSELS AND OTHER OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT SOME OF WHICH ARE
REALLY ONLY ATTAINABLE BY THE
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH
HAS EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION
RAILROADS FOR EXAMPLE THAT
REMAIN ONE OF OUR MOST
DIFFICULT- PROBLEMS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS- AND BECAUSE DIESEL
PARTICULATE MATTER MAKES UP 30%
OF ALL THE PARTICULATE MATTER-
FROM- THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. THIS IS- NOT A CRITERIA
POLLUTANT IT'S ONLY LISTED AS A
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT BUT WE
HAVE HAD- CONTINUAL
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE- THE
PIONEERING COMMUNITIES IN OUR
AB SIX SEVENTEEN AT PROGRAM AND
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM THE
COMMUNITIES AND A VERY CLEAR
VOICE THAT THEY WANT TO SEE US-
MOVING IN THE DIRECTION OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES A SOLUTION
NOT FOR GLOBAL WAR BUT FOR THE
GROUND LEVEL POLLUTION THAT THE
EXPERIENCE THERE IN THE IN. THE
INTERIM SALUTE THEM FOR ME
TECHNOLOGIES THEY WILL TO SEE A
ARE THEY WANT TO SEE US MAP. SO
WITH THAT IN MY- HI I THINK
WHAT I TO SAY IS WE ARE HAVE TO
PURSUE SOME NEW AND MORE
AGGRESSIVE STRAY. THAT RAPIDLY
A IS THERE EMISSION TECHNO. AND
ALSO TO RE MOBY PATTERN TO RID
THE ONE TRAVELED FOR AS LONG AS
WE CAN TO HAVE COMBUSTION THE
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS NEEDED TO MEET OUR
SB THIRTY TWO CLIMATE CHART
TARGET BY TWENTY THIRTY AS WELL
AS- TO GET TO THAT CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOAL OF THE STATE IS
SET FOR TWENTY FOUR AND FIVE.
SIX AT THAT LETTER BE REQUIRED
NOT THAT WE CAN GET. OUT
BUSINESS AT HE WAS SO. IN ORDER
TO GET THAT LOVE OF. WE'RE NEED
TO ASSURE THAT EVERYBODY AND
CAL. HAS ACCESS TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IN ONE FORM
OR ANOTHER AS WELL AS
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THOSE AB
FUELS ROADS AND COMMUNICATIONS
AND WE'RE GONNA NEED TO WORK TO
BUILD SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
THAT IMPROVE PEOPLE'S TRAVEL
CHOICES AND REDUCE THE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED OR VMT. WE'VE
MADE PROGRESS AS MY CHARTS HAVE
SHOWED DESPITE THE LACK OF. IN
THE COMPLETE ACTION ON TRADE SO
LIKE SHIPS. AND TRUCKS AND WELL
AS THE END IN V. MY TRAVELED
WHICH MEANS TRANSIT EMISSIONS
ARE ACTUALLY MOVING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION AND OUR JOB IS
GOTTEN HARDER BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL SAFE FOR ALL THAT- TOOK
AWAY CALIFORNIA'S AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRES ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
OR TO REGULATE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM- MOTOR VEHICLES.
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE'VE ALSO
BEEN SO WILLING TO RESTORE OUR
A RIGHT TO THE ACT- BUTEVEN
WITH FULL COOPERATION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT
WE WOULD STILL NOT HAVE.
EVERYTHING WE NEED WE HAVE TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON TRANSPORTATION
AND STRIVE FOR A FUTURE WHERE
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA CAN
ATTAIN THE KINDS OF- TOTALLY
EMISSIONS FREE- LIFE THAT. IS
WHAT IS WHAT IS NEEDED YOU
KNOW. I CAN'T HELP BUT SAY
THAT- IT'S BEEN FIFTY YEARS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S AND WORKING
TO DRIVE DOWN EMISSIONS AND
DURING THAT TIME IT'S
IMPRESSIVE WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO AND WE'RE LOOKING TO BUY
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD
BECAUSE OF THAT. YES BUT IT
TOOK. FIFTY TO DO IT IN A WAY
THAT ALSO MAINTAINED ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND I'M AND WE'VE KNOWN
FOR ALMOST LOG THAT THE SAME
AMBITIONS WHICH ARE COST BY
BURNING UP. FEEL ARE ALSO WERE
IS BECAUSE THEY ARE TO WARM
THIS IS NOT THIS IS NOT NEW
INFORMATION THATWE SOME SAVE
AND DEALT WITH. KING AND THEN
IN NUMBER OF SAM TO. CAN TO
WILL A- STILL MAINTAIN OUR PA%
GROWTH OUR ACTON GROWTH. AND
THOSE ARE. BUT. WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO REACH OUR GOAL OF THAT
PACE. VACATION AND TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WE KNOW ARE ALWAYS WHAT'S
GOING TO BE NEEDED AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO ENLIST THE
SUPPORT OF EVERYBODY WHO HAS A
ROLE- INCLUDING NOT ONLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR BUT THE PUBLIC
AT LARGE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IN PARTICULAR. WE ARE SEEING A
LOT OF ACTIVITY IN INTEREST IN
THOSE AREAS. TO ACHIEVE THIS
NEW PARADIGM WE'RE GONNA NEED A
NUMBER OF NEW- TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
WIDESPREAD ELECTRIFICATION WITH
A 100% OF A LECTERN PASSENGER
VEHICLE SALES BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. AND A COMPLETE TURNOVER
OF VEHICLES TO ELECTRIC BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE THESE ARE
JUST WHAT THE MODEL SHOT WITH
SOME OF THE- ON A GOAL THAT WE-
MADE UP BECAUSE IT WE THINK
IT'S NOW TO. IT'S A GOAL THAT
MAY. OUR SHOWS ONLY WAY THINK
WE CAN MEET THE STANDARDS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN SET. WE NEED
TO HAVE SUSTAINED INVESTMENTS
AND POLICIES THAT WE CAN-
MAINTAIN OVER TIME- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE. VERY CLOSE
TO A TIPPING POINT FOR
COMMERCIALIZATION FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IN A NUMBER
OF AREAS WHERE TECHNOLOGY COSTS
AND DECLINING AND AS
INFRASTRUCTURE EXPANDS WE ARE
ALREADY WITH. ARE BEGINNING TO
SEE THE TRAJECTORY TO REACH
ZERO EMISSION TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK STILL
NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND IT SURE
THAT THESE INVESTMENTS CUT
ACROSS MULTIPLE MODES OF TRAVEL.
IT'S GOING TO. BE THAT A BIG
PART OF THE TASK BUT TECHNOLOGY
ALONE IT'S NOT GONNA BE ENOUGH
TO DO IT BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL
GOING TO BE A LOT OF. INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES OUT THERE IN
SOME SOURCES WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO-
TO REPLACE SO. INVESTING IN
ALTERNATIVES- INCLUDING. GREAT
MUCH GREATER ACCESS TO TRANSIT
IS ALSO VERY CLEAN- COMPLETE
STREETS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS A WALKING AND BIKING
AS WELL AS PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
THE NEED TO COMMUTE. ARE ALL
THINGS THAT THAT HAVE TO BE
DONE AND AGAIN PROVIDE A MORE
INTEGRATED DO SEND
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
PLANNING THAT INCREASES AT
THAT. I MEAN THAT WILL INCREASE
THE RANGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS THESE THINGS ARE
INEXTRICABLY LINKED TO EACH
OTHER AND I KNOW IT'S GONNA BE
ASKING- COLLEAGUE. EVEN CLIMATE
ADVICE. KATE CORD TO TALK MORE
THAT IN A BIT BUT AT THE HEART
OF A LOT OF THIS IT REMAINS THE
INEQUITIES THAT KEEP PEOPLE
FROM- TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
NEWEST TECHNOLOGIES OR FROM A
FORTY HOUSING AND PLACES THAT'S
CLOSER TO WHERE THEY WORK AND
TOO- OTHER KINDS OF RESOURCES
THAT. YOU NEED AND SO PUTTING
IN PLACE HIGH QUALITY TRAVEL
AND HOUSING OPTIONS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE NECESSARY.
I FELT REALLY GOOD. SORRY OKAY
GOT IT- I AM A I MISIDENTIFIED
TWO WOULD BE SPEAKING FOR A OPR
ACTUALLY IS IT WILL BE RELEASED
BACK WORTH- SO I JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY SAY BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR ME AND I THERE ARE A LOT OF
WORDS ON THESE PAGES THAT WITH
THE EASE THAT GO WITH THESE
LIGHTS- THAT AMONG THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITHIN
THE PURVIEW OF WHAT A RB IS
ALREADY. ABLE TO DO OR IS
REQUIRED TO DO INCLUDE
STRENGTHENING OUR GUIDELINES
FOR EVALUATING. THE OUT PLANS
THAT COMMUNITIES DEVELOP UNDER
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE- THIS IS
GOING THROUGH THE- AND PO'S.
WE'RE DEVELOPING ARE CLEAN
MILES STANDARD REGULATION UNDER
SB TEN FOURTEEN WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS FROM RIDE HAILING
COMPANIES. LIKE UBER AND LEFT-
BY GETTING THEM INVOLVED IN
ELECTRIFICATION AND PULLING AND
OTHER MEASURES. AND WE ARE
LOOKING OUT WHERE EVER WE HAVE
DISCRETION IN FUNDING. TO
INCREASE THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND DISADVANTAGED CAN
TODAY'S INCLUDING A NEW PILOT
PROJECT THIS YEAR. CALL THE
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECT OR STEP. THAT
WILL PROVIDE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS. TO FUND
INTEGRATED LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
ADDRESS COMMUNITY. NEEDS BUT-
CARP OBVIOUSLY CANNOT DO THIS
ON ITS OWN. IT WE HAVE TO BE OR
DATING ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
AND ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT.
WELL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
PARTICULAR ARE KEY TO
INFLUENCING HOW COMMUNITIES ARE
BUILT AND WHAT TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE. SO
LOOKING TO TRY TO FIND WAYS TO
REQUIRE THAT TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS IN PLANS. WILL
DEMONSTRATE HOW THEY MEET
COMMUNITY NEEDS. IN WAYS THAT
REDUCE OVERALL NEEDS TO DROP
FIVE AND THE SENATE. HOUSING IN.
FILL YES THAT'S CLOSE TO
TRANSIT AND JOB UNDER. WELL AS
LOOK AT WAYS TO IMPROVE. THEIR.
ABILITY AS A AS A AS- AN- YEAH.
WE NEED TO LOOK WE EVEN BE ON
THE ACT THAT WERE TAKING NOW
TOWARDS THE GOAL OF CARBON NEW
AND THAT IS SO A STEP. WHAT
MOST OF OUR EXISTING PLANS AND
PROGRAMS HAVE THOUGHT TO DO-
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO STABILIZE
CLIMATE THE CARBON DIOXIDE AND
OTHER GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THAT ARE GENERATED NOT JUST BY
VEHICLES BUT ALSO BY POWER
PLANTS INDUSTRIAL PROCESS SEES
AS WELL AS BY- ARE ARE NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS MUST BE LESS
THAN OR EQUAL TO THE AMOUNT OF
CARBON DIOXIDE THAT IS REMOVED
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. THERE WAS
OUR SPECIAL REPORT ISSUED IN
LATE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY THE-
YOU AND I. P. C. C. PANEL
SHOWED THAT IN ORDER TO LIMIT
GLOBAL TEMPERATURE INCREASES TO
ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES CELSIUS
WE WOULD NEED TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY GLOBALLY TO AVOID
THE WORST IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE I IT'S VERY SAY THAT FAR
FROM. AND GIVEN WHAT'S GOING ON
MAY OTHER OF WORLD THE CALL
THESE KIND OF MAY NOW AS THOUGH
THEY BE OUT OF OUT OF REACH I
WE KNOW THAT WHEN IN CAL ARE
PULLED. DEMONSTRATE THE
AVAILABILITY OF AT. AND TO SHOW
THEY CAN BE TO. IN WAYS THAT
ARE. FOR AND ACTUALLY GENERATE
I CAN INVESTMENT THAT WE CAN
LEAD THE WAY AND GET OTHERS TO
JOIN WITH US IN THESE IN THESE
KINDS OF ACTIVITIES. I WANT TO
MENTION IN THAT REGARD A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT WERE WORKING ON
WITH RESPECT TO CARBON CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION AS WELL AS
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE OF CO TWO
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. AND THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING ON
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS AS
WELL- FIRST OUR BOARD ADOPTED A
PROTOCOL FOR USE IN THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD THAT IS
ALREADY BEGINNING TO ATTRACT
SOME ATTENTION FROM- INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE LOOKING TO.
DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE'S
TECHNOLOGY TO CAPTURE AND STORE
CARBON FROM- OIL REFINERY OR
CEMENT AND OTHER INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES. ARE THERE A NUMBER
OF VERY SMALL AT THAT MOMENT
PILOT PROJECTS. LOOKING AT RACK
AIR TOP CO TWO BUT AGAIN THIS
TO BE A LAW OF WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO MAKE THIS TECH.
SCALABLE AND ECONOMIC WE NEED
TO BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
LOOKING AT THESE TECHNOLOGIES
AND FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN-
PIONEER SOME OF THEM. AND AGAIN
OUR NATURAL LANDS ALSO NEED TO
BE GIVEN A FAIR AMOUNT OF
ATTENTION TO BECOME- THE KIND
OF CARBON SINKS THAT THEY NEED
TO BE THIS HAS BEEN SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN. TALKING ABOUT AND
WORKING ON BUT AS YOU KNOW THE
ONE OF THE MOST VISIBLE OBVIOUS
EFFECTS OF OUR AT CURRENT
LEVELS OF- OF A BUILDUP OF
GREENHOUSE GASES HAS BEEN. THAT
WHERE MORE FIRE PRONE AND THAT
OUR FIRES ARE LARGER AND MORE
DESTRUCTIVE THAN THEY USED TO
BE- WE AT A R. B. HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME. THINKING ABOUT A
LOOKING AT FIRE AND THE ROLE OF
CO TWO FROM BUYERS. AT ONE OF
THE MOST OBVIOUS EFFECTS OF
FIRES IN NEAR ANY COMMUNITY
EVEN WHEN YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY
DIRECTLY IN THE LINE OF THE
DESTRUCTION IS THE EFFECT OF
SMOKE AND WHAT IT DOES TO
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO BREATHE.
IT'S SCARY AND IT'S AWFUL- WE
NEED TO FIND WAYS THAT WE CAN
SAFELY ALLOW FOR BURNING ON
LANDS WHERE THE ONLY WAY TO
STORE THE HEALTH OF THE FOREST
IS TO ALLOW BURNING A PAST
COMBINED OTHER. BETTER
MANAGEMENT OF FIRES BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT LEVY A PART OF
OUR JOB IS BEING TO FIND WAYS
TO ALLOW FOR THERE TO BE. THE
KIND OF MEANING THAT THE TWO
BANDS CATASTROPHIC. WHAT FIRES
DURING THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION IN THE HAND OUT
ABOUT FIRE I THINK I'M GOING TO
SKIP. READING THIS PART OF THE
TESTIMONY BECAUSE IT'S EASIER
FOR YOU TO READ IT FOR YOURSELF
THE ONLY OTHER THING I WANTED
TO TOUCH ON IN THIS THAT YOU
VAST. IS ISSUE OF ACCOUNTING.
BECAUSE THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
FRANKLY IS A IN THE WORLD- WHEN
IT COMES TO. HAVING A RIGOROUS
AND CREDIBLE SYSTEM FOR
ACCOUNTING FOR EMISSIONS AND
THAT IS THE BEDROCK UPON WHICH
ALL OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS NEED
TO REST BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY FOR
REGULATED INDUSTRY OR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THE REDUCTIONS THAT WERE
GENERATING BY OUR PROGRAMS ARE
REAL SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOR DECADES NOW TO USE SCIENCE.
TO PURSUE POLICIES AND PUT IN
THE RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT
OUR ACCOUNTING IS ACCURATE A
AND VERIFIABLE BOTH AB THIRTY
TWO AND SB THIRTY TWO FOCUSED
ON REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM THE
FOSSEL SECTOR AND THOSE
INVENTORIES ONLY INCLUDE ENERGY
TRANSPORTATION AND INDUSTRIAL
EMISSIONS WE AT CARP HAVE
SEPARATELY PUBLISHED A NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS GREENHOUSE
GAS INVENTORY WHICH INCLUDES
THE WILDFIRE EMISSIONS THAT
ARE. DEPICTED ON THE SLIDES
THAT YOU HAVE BUT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THAT COME FROM A
NATURAL DISASTER LIKE WILD
FIRES SHOULD NOT BE MEASURED
OR- POOLED TOGETHER WITH
EMISSIONS THAT COME FROM- THE
SOURCES THAT ARE ANTHROPOGENIC
THAT WE CAUSE URSELVES NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT A BIT GREENHOUSE
GASES SUCH AS WILD FIRES AND
FOREST FIRES. HAVE BEEN
OCCURRING SINCE LONG BEFORE
CLIMATE CHANGE WAS NOTICED AND
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO OCCUR AS
CLIMATE CONTINUES TO CHANGE AND
WILL PERSIST EVEN IF WE WERE
ULTIMATELY TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
OF CLIMATE CHANGE SO WHILE
SCIENCE CAN NOW CONCLUSIVELY
ATTRIBUTE INDIVIDUAL EXTREME
ADVANCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
DETERMINE WHAT TYPES OF EVENTS
ARE MADE WORSE BY CLIMATE
CHANGE SUCH AS HURRICANE SIX.
BOTH MARTIN TO RECOGNIZE THAT
SOME OF THESE OF ARE A SYMPTOM
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND ARE NOT
TO BE- INCLUDED- WHEN IT COMES
TO FIGURING OUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM THE
OVERWHELMING CONSENSUS OF
CLIMATE SCIENTISTS IS THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ANTHROPOGENIC
MEANING THAT WE HUMANS HAVE
BECAUSE THESE EIGHT
CONCENTRATIONS TO INCREASE AND
THEREFORE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE AVERAGE GLOBAL
TEMPERATURE INCREASES AND THE
MORE EXTREME VERSION OF EVENTS
THAT THIS CAUSES SEC SO. THIS
IS WHERE WE INTEND TO KEEP ON
PUTTING OUR ENERGY AND WHERE WE
THINK WE CAN MAKE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE IN CALIFORNIA SO- IN
CONCLUSION OF LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INTEREST AND
WILLINGNESS TO CONVENE OF ON
THIS SECOND ANNUAL REPORT OF AB
ONE NINETY SEVEN AND- TO JUST
TO POINT OUT THAT WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE FIRST ADOPTED AB
THIRTY TWO AND TWO THOUSAND SIX
AS WELL AS THE RENEWABLE
ORTFOLIO STANDARD LEGISLATION.
THERE WERE WALKS PREDICTIONS
THAT THOSE GOALS WERE NOT
ACHIEVABLE AND THAT THEY WOULD
BE TO COST AND SEND THE FATE OF
THE WRONG DIRECTION NOW WE KNOW
I'M ONLY A FEW SHORT YEARS LATE.
THAT THOSE PROJECT THIS WRONG
THAT WE WERE RIGHT TO CONTRA.
IN THE ABILITY OF OUR OUR
SCIENTISTS AND ARE INVENTORS
AND OUR OUR CITIZENS- TO. MAKE
PROGRESS AND TO UP PUT THEIR
MINDS TO SUCCEEDING AND WE'VE
DONE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT TO
INCREASE- TO IT THE CARBONIZED
OUR ELECTRICITY GOAL AS WELL AS
TO CONTINUE OUR WORK ON
REDUCING OUR AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES. BUT FRANKLY I THINK
WE WOULD BE WRONG TO RELY ON
THE PAST SUCCESS TO ASSUME THAT
WE CAN MAKE IT TO OUR TWENTY
THIRTY AND TWENTY FORTY FIVE
CLIMATE GOALS. BECAUSE THESE
ARE MUCH HARDER TO ACHIEVE AN
AUNT BECAUSE FRANKLY DONNELLY
IN WASHINGTON BUT IN OTHER
MAJOR EMITTING COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD THE POLITICALWILL TO
ACT IS NOT. EVIDENT IN FACT
THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT
PEOPLE ARE LESS WILLING TO
COLLABORATE AND COOPERATE THAT
SEEM TO BE. WHEN WE MET LEAD
MEETINGS THE COUNTRIES OF THE
WORLD MET. IN PARIS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN- EVEN IF WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN BEATING BACK THE
ATTACKS ON CALIFORNIA'S
AUTHORITY WHICH WE BELIEVE WE
WILL BE AND WE CERTAINLY SHOULD
EIGHT NEVER THE LESS WE CAN'T
JUST DO IT BY OURSELVES SO. I
THINK THAT OUR GREATEST HOPE
LIES IN MAKING OURSELVES. IF
YOU. TRAIN OUR SYSTEM TO ONE WE
BUILD AROUND A RE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND- THE
HOUSING FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT SIMPLY DOWN IN THAT
GREENHOUSE GASES AT ALL AND
THAT WE FIND WAYS TO TAKE THE-
ACCESSES THAT WE KNOW ARE GOING
TO EXIST BECAUSE THERE WILL BE
ACTIVITIES THAT AN ARRAY CO TWO
OUT OF THE ATMOSPHERE OF THE I
THINK WE SHOULD GOOD IN THAT
REGARD. HE MADE OF. OTHER TIME
WHEN YOU KNOW HE HAVE FACED
REALLY EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES
AND DANGERS AND RECOGNIZE THAT-
SOMETIMES YOU CANNOT- CONTINUE
TO HOLD OFF AND TWO HALF
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
ACTION THAT HAS REAL
CONSEQUENCES SO. THIS IS A
CHALLENGE THAT IS BEFORE ALL OF
US IT'S YOURS AS AS WELL AS
OURS AND- I AM. VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE THE WILL THAT WE SEEM TO
HAVE. IT IS OUR STATE AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR WHO
TELL US REGULARLY- HOW IN
INSTANT THEY ARE THAT WE ACT
AND THE I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON A THESE CHAT WHICH
IS WITH THANK YOU. I THINK THAT
UNDER TO HAVE OUR VICE CHAIR
GIVES THEM OPENING COMMENTS AND
HILL START OFF THE QUESTIONS
AND THEN I'LL- CALL MISTER
MONEY NEXT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. I GUESS MY COMMENTS-
JUST KEEP VERY BRIEF AND THAT.
AB WE APPRECIATE THE STEADINESS
AND LEADERSHIP WE'VE HAD THE
AIRBOARD THROUGH MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATION SO. THANK YOU
CHAIR NICHOLS FOR REMAINING- IN
PUBLIC SERVICE TRY STEADIEST
THROUGH SOME VERY. YEAH I WANT
TO IN THE GOOD TIMES ARE COMING
AYE AYE YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE IT
JUST KEEPS THE DARK TIMES JUST
SEEM TO KEEP- UNFOLDING- AND WE
WENT THROUGH IT ALL OVER THE
FALL- IN VERY REAL TIME.
PEOPLE'S COMMUNITIES KEEP
BURNING DOWN AN- HOUR GOES OFF
FOR. HOW MANY MORE KIDS WENT TO
THE DOCTOR BECAUSE OF THEIR
ASTHMA. WE KNOW THESE IMPACTS
WELL BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH
IN MY MIND TO. QUANTIFY THE
TRUE FISCAL RISK AROUND THEM
EITHER AND WHAT IT ACTUALLY
COSTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE SOME OF
THE AIR STUDIES THAT HAVE COME
OUT OF. TWENTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS WE FACES STATE IN ALL
THESE COSTS BUT I'M HOPING THIS
YEAR WE CAN. REALLY SCREW UP TO
THE FISCAL RISK THAT CLIMATE
POSES TO THE STATE AND OUR
BUDGET AS A WHOLE- I WANTED TO
ASK YOU JUST BRIEFLY. YES TWO
CENTRAL QUESTIONS- ONE OF THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. AND
WHETHER YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE STATE OF THE MARKET THERE-
YOU KNOW EL CFS IS DRIVING A
LOT OF THE BEHAVIOR ON THE
TRANSPORTATION SIDE RIGHT NOW.
BUT I STILL I MEAN WHEN THE
PUBLIC AT LEAST LOOKS WHO
AREN'T TRADERS AN ART TRADE OF
UP TO SPEED ON. THE ALLOWANCE
ALLOCATION SCHEMES WHEN THEY
SEE SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN
DOLLARS A TON. AND WHERE THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND I
THINK WAS SOCIAL COST OF CARBON
THEIR STUDY THIRTY FIVE OR
FORTY FIVE DOLLARS A TIME AND
NOW I THINK MOST RECENT NOW SEE
SHOW ABOUT SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS A
TON- IS OUR PRICE ON CARBON
ACCURATELY REFLECTING. THE TRUE
SOCIAL COSTS IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW. THE PRICE OF
ALLOWANCES SO THE FLOOR PRICE
EVEN WITH THE ADDER THAT THE
MARKET IS NOW PUTTING ON AT
BECAUSE WE'RE NO LONGER TRADING
AT JUST THE FLOOR OR WHERE IT
CONSISTENTLY. A BIT ABOVE THE
FLOOR- IN- THE OPTIONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HOLDING- DOES NOT
REFLECT THE SOCIAL COST OF
CARBON AND RECENT WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE. ON THAT ON THAT
ISSUE INDICATES THAT PROBABLY
THE NUMBERS THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS LOOKING OUT
ARE ALSO LOW- BECAUSE THE- THE
MODELING AND THE CURRENT
INFORMATION CLEARLY I SHOWING
THAT. THE BUILD UP OF GASES AND
THE- DAMAGE BEING CAUSED IS
GREATER IT'S COMING FASTER I
GUESS TO BE A BETTER WAY TO PUT
THAT THE THINGS THAT. PEOPLE
WERE PREDICTING WHAT HAPPENED
BY THE END OF THE CENTURY ARE
HAPPENING EARLY IN THE CENTURY
INSTEAD SO- THERE'S NO REASON
TO THINK THAT TWENTY DOLLARS OF
THàNH IS THE RIGHT. PRICE FOR
CARBON THE REASON WHY THE SET
THE PRICES AS WE DID IT AT THE
TIME KNEW THAT THAT THE BY TO
BE. REAL THE FOR CALL OF THE
DAY OUT JEFF OUR- OF GLOBAL WAR.
FOR MANY. WAS THE WE WERE TO
SHOW. COULD HAVE A CAP ON TO
THIS THE ALL NO THOUGHT OF THE
TIME. THAT WOULD PERTAIN. OF
PRODUCE UP OUR PRO. WHERE YOU
WOULD HAVE ACT. READ OF.
EVERYBODY WAS LOOKING AT
MARKETS WAS ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW STATE COULD EVEN DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS SO OUR GOAL
WAS TO. CREATE A SYSTEM WHICH
WAS- DURABLE AND- COULD BE
IMPLEMENTED. AND THAT- FRANKLY
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE SUBJECT TO
IT WHICH SHOULD MAINLY WAS THE
REFINERS ON THE POWER PLANTS
AND- AND DRIVERS WHO. BY
GASOLINE- COULD LIVE WITH THAT
IT WOULD BE THAT IT WOULD HAVE
RESULTS IT WOULD WORK BUT IT
WOULDN'T. BE SO- ONEROUS THAT
IT WOULD EITHER DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVELY OR OR
HEARD OUR CONSUMERS AND I THINK
WE DROVE DOWN A LINE THERE-
AND- AND WE DID IT I FEEL LIKE
WE DID IT VERY WELL AND THE
FACT THAT WE'VE HAD THIS. ROBOT
SYSTEM WITH A CALLBACK ALTHOUGH
THAT'S ALSO BEING CHALLENGED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOW HAS
ALSO BEEN A PROOF THAT WE CAN'T
EVEN DO THIS THE CRUX OF. THE
BUT INTERNATIONAL BOUNDARY BUT
HAVING SAID THAT. WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD AND YOU THE CAP
AND TRADE SYSTEM TO DROP FIVE
MORE REDUCTIONS. WE'RE GOING TO.
TAKE TO SEE THAT GOES UP THERE
ARE OTHER WAYS YOU COULD DO
THAT YOU CAN PUT A ON. THROUGH
ATTACK IT OF THAT'S A BEEN AN
IDEA THAT MEN PEOPLE THE YEARS
HAVE HAVE THOUGHT WAS A BETTER
FAIRER SYSTEM. SO YOU KNOW WE
ALL AND I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT WE- WE
LOOKED AT THE CARBON I JUST- IN
IN REGARD TO THE CAP AND TRADE
PRICE THAT. WE SAW THAT IS
BEING ADDED ON TO THE COST OF
THAT- CONSUMERS WOULD BE PAYING
TO MEET OUR OTHER REGULATORY-
PROGRAMS AS WELL SO THIS MIXED
PROGRAM THAT WE HAD. WITH THE
EMISSION STANDARDS FOR THE
VEHICLES AND THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARDS ETCETERA IT ALL
AGAIN TOGETHER SO. AGAIN YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE COST OF
CARBON BUT- A WE CHANGE OR IF
AND WHEN WE CHANGE THE CAP AND
TRADE SYSTEM AS THE MAN TO
CLOSE TO BECAUSE I THINK. IS A
THAT CAN HAVE TO DISCUSS AS WE
DEVELOP THE NEXT COPING. IS FOR
THAT I THINK THROUGH THE- THIS
OAK POPPING UP EVEN THROUGH THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS I
KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE AN ISSUE
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CLIMATE
BUDGET HEARING THE SENATE. OR
ST TWO WEEKS EVERY TEN DAYS OR
SO. SO WE'LL PROBABLY BE
TRAILING DOWN ON THAT FURTHER
AND NOT TO SAY THAT THE PURPOSE
OF. OUR EMISSIONS TRADING
PROGRAM IS TO GENERATE REVENUE.
IT'S BEING LOOKED AT THAT THAT
WAY BUT IT'S IT INTENDED TO.
BUILD CERTAINTY AND- SOME KIND
OF BACKSTOP ON THE SYSTEM BUT
WE'RE GONNA BE RELYING ON A
MORE AND MORE. COURT THAT THE
MODELS ARE RIGHT- TO DRIVE
BROADER EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
SO. LOOK FOR ENGAGING WITH YOU
ON THAT THE ONE OTHER THING I
WANT TO ASK- IS THE- STRUCK BY
YOUR NATURAL WORKING LANDS
ANALYSIS. AND I'M WONDERING
WHERE WE WOULD BE IN TERMS OF
THE TRAJECTORY TO HITTING OUR
SB THIRTY TWO GOALS IF WE
ACTUALLY DID ACCOUNT FOR
EMISSIONS FROM THE NATIONAL IN
WORKING LAND SECTOR SO SAVING
INVENTORY WAS. WHAT I WOULD
CONSIDER COMPLETE CONSIDERED
SORT OF A IT'S ONE IT'S ONE
SLICE OF THE INVENTORY RIGHT
NOW BUT IF WE SAID OKAY WE'RE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT. FUGITIVE
EMISSIONS NETWORKING LANCE. HOW
ARE WE HOW FAR. BEHIND ARE WE-
IF WE LOOK AT THINGS. THROUGH
THAT LENS AND AGAIN I DON'T
WANT TO BE A DOWNER HERE TO ONE
WELL IT'S NOT IT'S NOT EQUAL TO
BUT IT'S A VERY SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER IT'S A BIG NUMBER-
CLOSER TO. WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
TARGETING WITH THE EXISTING
REGULATORY PROGRAMS AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS OF COURSE
WHY I'M- EMPHASIZING SO MUCH
YEAH THEY NEED TO GET AFTER.
WAYS TO CAPTURE AND RE USE OR
STORE KERR BUT CAN WE COUNT THE
SAME WAY I KNOW I BECAUSE I
KEEP THINKING. OKAY WE NEED A
THE- EARLY STAGE INVENTORY LIKE
BYRON SHEER DID THAT THEN LED
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF SOME KIND
OF MARKET. IS THAT THE WRONG
WAY TO BE THINKING ABOUT
SOLUTIONS IN THE NATURAL
WORKING LANCE BASS OR DO YOU
THINK THE SCIENCE IS SOLID
ENOUGH THAT WE ACTUALLY CAN
GET. AN ACCURATE INVENTORY SO
WE KNOW. YOU KNOW WHEN WE
INVEST IN THIS WETLANDS
RESTORATION PROJECT OR A RICE
FIELD CONVERSION OR A FORCE%
MANAGEMENT PROJECT THAT. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE AT LEAST. SOME
ACCURATE BASELINE THERE AND
SOME CERTAINTY I WOULD JUST SO
YES AND NO MY SIMPLISTIC ANSWER
TO THAT IS. WE PROBABLY- OVER
CREDIT HAVE CERTAIN WE ARE
ABOUT EMISSIONS FROM WHAT WE
THINK OF AS CONVENTIONAL
SOURCES COMBUSTION THAT FUELS.
BUT WE CAN'T PUT ON THE MONITOR
ON A STACK AND ACTUALLY MEASURE
THE CO TWO COMING OUT OF THAT
SACK. AND YOU CAN YOU CAN HEAR
THAT UP WITH- THE FUEL THAT'S
GOING INTO THE THAT SAME. CALL
IT AND THE CARBON. OF THE FUEL.
ROB VERY WELL SO WE CAN FEEL
QUITE CONFIDENT THAT WE KNOW
WHAT THOSE EMISSIONS ARE WHEN
IT COMES TO- FUGITIVE EMISSIONS
BURNING- IT'S MUCH MORE ABOUT
ESTIMATING- BUT THE TECHNIQUES
FOR EXAMPLE- MEASURING THAT IT
USING- INFRARED TECHNOLOGY TO
MEASURE WHAT'S GOING ON OVER A
WHOLE FOREST AREA- HAVE
IMPROVED REALLY DRAMATICALLY SO
THAT- I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA OF
MORE THAN JUST A GAS OR A-
ORDER VALUE TO THAT WE'RE YOU
KNOW. WE'RE GETTING DOWN TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU COULD
APPROPRIATELY SAY A PARTICULAR
REGULATION OR A PARTICULAR-
TYPE OF- CREDITING PROGRAM FOR
IMPROVE FOREST PRACTICES WOULD
ACHIEVE RESULTS AND YOU'D BE
PRETTY YOU'D BE ABLE TO SAY
WHAT THOSE WERE WITH A
REASONABLE DEGREE OF ACCURACY.
SO I'LL JUST WRAPPED THEN WITH
THIS WAY TELL ME IF I'M I'M
UNDERSTANDING YOUR COMMENT
RIGHT. WE CAN SPEND A LOT OF
TIME WORKING ON POWER FUELS
BUILDINGS SORT OF THESE
TRADITIONAL DIRECT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS SOURCES BUT IF WE
LEAVE. NATURAL WORKING LANDS
FUGITIVE MISSIONS THAT SECTOR
WE'RE REALLY ONLY TALKING ABOUT
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE PROBLEM IS
IT I MEAN ROUGH ROUGHLY HALF.
THAT YOU GOT IT THANKS THANK
YOU. CENTER MONNING. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
CONVENING IN MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE TODAY IN
YOUR WORK EVERY DAY- LEADING
CARBON KEEPING US FOCUSED- I
WANT TO PICK UP ON SENATOR
STERN'S QUESTION ABOUT THE
PRICE OF ALLOWANCES NEWMAN
MENTIONED YOU AGREED THAT WE
UNDER PRICE BASED ON ESTIMATES
OF IMPACTS AND COSTS IN YOU
SAID IT'S SOMETHING TO LOOK AT
IN THE NEXT SCOPING PLAN.
WHAT'S THE TIMETABLE FOR THAT
IN. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT.
CARP HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
ADJUST THE PRICING ON THESE
ANNOUNCES THAT IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS
THAT ACCURATE YES YES- I THINK
THAT- THE WORKSHOPS THAT ARE
UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW THE CARD IS
CONVENING ARE ALREADY AT
ELICITING A LOT OF RESPONSE.
AND IDEAS FROM REGULATED
INDUSTRIES AS WELL AS FROM
SCIENTISTS AND ACADEMICS AND A
AND MEMBERS OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ABOUT WHAT
IDEAS THEY'D LIKE TO SEE
PURSUED IN THE NEXT PLAN
CLEARLY WE DO NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE A TAX THAT
IS BEYOND THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE
COULD DO- AND PRICING. UNDER
THE CAP AND TRADE SYSTEM IF WE
WERE TO RAISE THE FLOOR PRICE
WE WOULD HAVE TO- GO THROUGH-
YOU KNOW HOLE I NOTICE AND RULE
MAKING PROCEEDING AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE HOPE IS A
DECLINING POOL. OF ENTERED
THERE AND PART OF WHAT THE
DILEMMAS I THINK BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A QUOTA ECONOMY
WIDE TO CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
IT REALLY DIRECTLY IMPACTS ONLY
THE PEOPLE WHO AFTER BY
ALLOWANCES AND THAT'S A SEVEN
HUNDRED. ENTITIES ROUGHLY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO IT'S
NOT LIKE I HAVE TO GO BUY
ALLOWANCES WHEN I- TURN ON MY
GAS WATER HEATER WHICH I STILL
HAVE YOU KNOW THAT SORT OF
THIN SO IF WE WERE TO STARTED
TO ROLL DOWN. TOGETHER AT THE
SMALLER- SOURCES- WE WOULD HAVE
TO ALSO EXPAND THE COVERAGE OF
THE PROGRAM AND THE WAY THE
PROGRAM OPERATES SO THAT'S AN
OPTION YEAH BUT IT MAY NOT BE
THE ONLY ONE. THANK YOU. AND I
THINK THE OVER ARCHING THEME OF
YOUR PRESENTATION IS. THE
INCREASED URGENCY OF THE CRISIS
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS- AND-
WELL WE CAN'T DO IT ALONE IN
CALIFORNIA. AS CALIFORNIA. WE
NEED TO DO MORE THAN WE'RE
DOING NOW. I THINK IT'S- IN
YOUR TESTIMONY AND IT'S KIND OF
COMMON KNOWLEDGE THAT WERE.
DOING A RELATIVELY GOOD JOB ON
RENEWABLES IN AND DEVELOPING.
THOSE RESOURCES AND MARKETS BUT
IT'S ON THE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED WHERE WERE FACING OUR
CHALLENGE YOU ALSO REFERENCED.
BUILDING COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSING. COULD YOU EXPAND A
LITTLE BIT ON THAT NEXUS OF HOW
WE GET PEOPLE OUT OF CARS AND
HOW DOES THAT LINK TO HOUSING
POLICY AND- WHAT ROLE. WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IT'S NOT BEING
DONE TO INCENTIVIZE IN WHERE
NECESSARY REQUIRING MANDATE-
MORE INFILL HOUSING AND- MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING OPTIONS CENTER
WELL I I'M KIND OF TAKING OFF-
THE THING IS THAT ARE RELATED
TO EACH OTHER BUT THEY'RE ALL
THEY'RE ALL LINKED AND IT'S
HARD TO KNOW WHICH IS THE
CHICKEN AND WHICH IS THE AG- IF
THERE ISN'T AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PEOPLE WILL LEAVE THE STATE
ULTIMATELY IF THEY CAN'T FIND A
PLACES TO LIVE- IF WE DON'T
HAVE- HOUSING THAT ENABLES
PEOPLE TO GET TO WORK WITHOUT A
SPENDING HOURS- STUCK IN
TRAFFIC WE'RE LOSING A LOT OF
PRODUCTIVITY AND WE'RE ALSO
INCREASING EMISSIONS AS THEY-
ARE SITTING PARKED IN TRAFFIC
AND- EMITTING- GREENHOUSE
GASES- IF WE CAN'T HAVE-
OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO WOULD
PREFER TO LIVE A HEALTHIER
LIFE- SO THAT THEY CAN WALK.
AND OR VIEWS CALLS OR OTHER
COMPLETELY EMISSIONS FREE
BENEFITS TO GET TO WHERE
WHEREVER IT IS THEY WANT TO GO
WE ALSO OFFER IN THE QUALITY OF
LIFE AS WELL AS IN OUR HEALTH
SO YOU KNOW WHERE EVER YOU PICK
UP. THE THREAD HERE IT ALL IT
CONNECTS BACK TOGETHER AGAIN
AND FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF OUR
IT. IS OUR KIND OF OVER ARE
BEING NATURE OF WHETHER WE'RE
SUCCESSFULLY NOT IF YOU WERE TO
ASK QUESTIONS YOU PUT AN ALERT
IN. A HIGH SPEED RAIL OR COLOR
AND SIZE HOW DOPPLER INTO
TURNING OVER THE VEHICLE PLATE
I COULDN'T REALLY ANSWER THE
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK WE
NEED. ALL THOSE. THANK YOU WILL
IT IS OPTION IT I THINK. IN MY
WE HAVE A HUGE PERCENT OF WERE
FORCE DRY IN LITERALLY HOURS
FROM. SOMETIME SUB STANDARD HOW
TO JOB IN A WITH UNATTAINABLE
IN ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO THE
OTHER PIECE OF THIS COMPLICATED
MATRIX INCLUDES PUBLIC TRANSIT.
IF THERE WERE AN INCREASE IN
ALLOWANCES THAT GENERATED EVEN
A EVEN A RELATIVELY MINOR
INCREASE THAT WOULD GENERATE
MORE MONEY THAT WE OUR VISION
IS TO INVEST THOSE REVENUES IN
CARBON REDUCING. ACTIVITIES
SOARING LEVELING THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR PEOPLE WHETHER IT'S
TO ACCESS SEWER ON. HAS ANYONE
GIVEN THOUGHT TO PROVIDING FREE
PASSES FOR PEOPLE THAT USE
PUBLIC TRANSIT USING. G. G. R.
F. REVENUES OR AN INCREASED
ALLOWANCE TO FUND. PUBLIC
ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRANSIT IT'S
NOT A SPECIFIC MEASURE THAT
WE'VE LOOKED AT BUT IT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED OVER TIME I THINK-
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME STUDIES
THAT HAVE SHOWN THAT EVEN
GIVING FREE PASSES TO PEOPLE TO
USE TRANSIT DONE. DON'T
NECESSARILY ACCOMPLISH THE
RESULT IF THE BUS DOESN'T COME
NEAR WHERE YOU WHERE YOU HAVE
TO GO YOU KNOW WE HAVE PEOPLE-
OF LOS ANGELES WHO HAVE TO.
CALL A LIFTER RIGHT UBER CAR
WHEN THEY GET OFF THEIR JOB YOU
KNOW ON THE LATE SHIFT AND THE
BUS STOPS TOO FAR AWAY FROM
THEIR HOUSE AND IT'S TOO
DANGEROUS TO GET FROM WHERE THE
BUS STOP IS TO WHERE THEY'RE
GOING HOME. I'D I DON'T MEAN TO
SOUND AS GLOOMY ABOUT THAT-
OPTION SO MUCH AS TO SAY THAT I
THINK WE REALLY DO NEED A SORT
OF A- OF A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO- THE
PERSON WHO IS A COMMUTING FROM
A SUB STANDARD HOUSING IF IT'S
THE RURAL HOUSING- THAT'S YOU
KNOW PEOPLE TO. CLOSER TO THE
EDGE OF THE FORESTED LAND IS AT
ANOTHER WORLD OF HURT IF
THEY'RE ALSO RUNNING THE RISK
OF HAVING THEIR PLACE BURNED
DOWN BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S TOO
CLOSE TO THE FIRE AREA SO IT'S
LIKE. WHERE DO YOU WHERE DO YOU
BEGIN I THINK YOU BEGIN BY
SAYING WHAT IS TAKE TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL COMMUNITY THAT'S A
LOW CARB AND COMMUNITY AND THEN
TRY TO COME WITH A RATE OF
MEASURES THANK YOU AND THEN I
KNOW THERE'S HAVE QUESTIONS OF
YOU KNOW. QUESTION ANSWER MR
PART PRESS. YOU TO DRAW THEN.
LITIGATION IN THE- WAIVER ON
ARMY STAND IF AMISH STANDARD.
COULD YOU IF YOU DO JUST STICK
STEP FOR ON WHERE WE ARE WITH
THAT TO THE EXTENT YOU'RE ABLE
TO THAT WERE STILL IN THE STATE
OF A OF LITIGATION THE- RULE-
CAME OUT TO- JUST A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO AND WE WENT TO COURT
TO CHALLENGE IT AND BRIEFING IS
GOING ON THE ROLE THAT OF THE
SECOND PART OF THAT RULE WHICH
IS THE ONE THAT. CHANGES THE
OBAMA STANDARDS AND EITHER
FREEZES THEM MORE MAKES THEM
MUCH LESS STRINGENT IS DUE OUT
ANY DAY NOW AND WE THINK THOSE
ARE PROBABLY END UP GETTING
LITIGATED TOGETHER THE THANK
YOU AND THEN. JUST FINAL ON
THAT. SOME OF THE AUTO
MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE
NEGOTIATED WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO WON EMBRACE THE
LOWER EMISSION STANDARDS. THOSE
HAVE BEEN BILATERAL
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE-
INDIVIDUAL MANUFACTURERS YES WE
HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE- NOBODY WANTS TO
RUN A FILE OF. ANTI TRUST LAWS
BUT- WE AS REGULATORS CAN WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THE REGULATED.
COMPANIES TO COME UP WITH-
ALTERNATIVE COMPLIANCE PATHS
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE WITH
FORD- VOLKSWAGEN HONDA AND BMW.
AND I THINK THAT. THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF SWIRL
GOING ON ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN
WHEN THE WHEN THE- EPA COMES
OUT WITH THEIR FINAL ROLE BUT-
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
COMPANIES. EITHER SIGNING ON TO
THOSE AGREEMENTS OR VOLUNTARILY
SAYING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO
BETTER THAN WHAT THOSE
STANDARDS. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THAT AND I DID JUST WANT TO
GIVE YOU A CHANCE ON THE
RECORD. TO CONFIRM THAT THESE
ARE THE RESULT OF BILATERAL
NEGOTIATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU AT A
SERIES QUESTIONS. ARE WE YOU
KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT THE
TRUMPETED STATION SECTOR YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE- NEED FOR
WIDESPREAD ELECTRIFICATION ARE
WE ON TARGET TO MEET OUR GOALS
BY THIRD TWENTY THIRTY WE'RE ON
THE PATH BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
DON'T WE DON'T SEE THE END IN
SIGHT YOU KNOW I THINK THE
TRAJECTORY. IS GENERALLY
CORRECT BUT IT NEEDS TO BE-
BAND TO THE CURVE NEEDS TO BE
BENT FURTHER TO MAKE TWENTY
THIRTY. AND I FELT WORKING ON A
NEW PLAN. A I MEAN SO WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE PROPOSED AS HE
TALKED ABOUT THE GOAL OF. CAP
AND TRADE AND- I WANT TO PUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH BUT IT'S ON
THE LIKE CAP AND TRADE THEN
ISN'T GONNA HELP GET US THERE-
IT'S SOME SORT OF A- MODEL OR
SAMPLE YOU KNOW FOR PEOPLE TO
LOOK AT BUT- YOU KNOW HOW HOW
ARE REALLY GOING TO REDUCE THE
PETROLEUM. DEMAND THAT'S OUT
THERE BOTH THE YOU KNOW FROM
OUR OUR CARS BUT ALSO FROM
REFINING FROM. PRODUCTION AND
SO FORTH. SO OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN
PRIMARILY ON- THE DEMAND. SIDE
TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR.
PETROLEUM TO BE- TO BE PRODUCED
STORE REFINED IN CALIFORNIA. BY
REDUCING THE NEED FOR PEOPLE TO
BUY THIS STUFF. BY A- INSISTING
THAT THE CARS BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND THAT THEY WERE PRODUCED
LESS GREENHOUSE GASES. AND
RAPIDLY INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES THAT
ARE OUT THERE- THERE ARE. AS
YOU KNOW- WAYS IN WHICH YOU
COULD SIMPLY. BAY AND
PRODUCTION OF PETROLEUM OR AT
LEAST DRIVE IN THAT DIRECTION.
BUT UP UNTIL NOW THE POLICY HAS
BEEN TO SAY. AS LONG AS WE'RE
STILL BUYING THIS STUFF. IT
WOULD BE PUTTING US AT AN
ECONOMIC DISADVANTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA. IF WE WERE TO
REQUIRE THAT EVERYBODY WHO
NEEDED TO PUT GAS IN THEIR CAR
HAD TO BUY GAS THAT WAS
IMPORTED. FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE
SO. THERE'S A YOU KNOW WE AE
WE'RE PART OF A LARGER. MARKET
HERE FOR- FOR PETROLEUM
PRODUCTS. BUT AS WE LOOK
TOWARDS THE FUTURE TOWARDS A
REALLY ZERO EMISSION FUTURE.
THEN WE HAVE TO START THINKING
ABOUT WHAT THE ROLE OF-
PETROLEUM VERSUS ALTERNATIVE
FEELS IS GONNA BE. AND HOW WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
FUEL FOR THE KIND OF CARS THAT
WE WANT TO SEE DRIVEN AND I. I
SAY CARS BUT REALLY IT'S
EVERYTHING IT'S THE TRUCKS- AND
IF THE BUSES AND- ALL THE OTHER
OUT. OF THE EQUIPMENT THAT WERE
OPERATING AS- BUT IF WE NEED TO
HAVE A PER. YOU SALES OF. MAY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE BE ELECT.
AND WERE NOT ANTI TO MEET THOSE
GOALS ARE SHOULD WE NOT BE
TALKED ABOUT HOW LEAVE REDUCE
EMISSIONS ARE PETROLEUM DEMAND
IN OTHER WAYS INCLUDING MAYBE
RACING THE FLOOR. OF CAP AND
TRADE ALLOWANCES. I DON'T THAT
WOULD BE A SORT OF AN INDIRECT
WAY OF GETTING ABIT- THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS I THINK THAT WE CAN
SEE THE MARKET WHICH REALLY IS
GROWING ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS
ALREADY- IMPROVE QUITE RAPIDLY
I DON'T MEAN TO PLACE TOO MUCH
EMPHASIS ON ADS AT THE
SUPERBOWL BUT I THINK THE FACT
THAT- EVEN GENERAL MOTORS WHICH
IS ONE OF THE COMPANIES THAT%
SUING US OVER OUR AUTHORITY
CHOSE TO USE THEIR- HOWEVER
MANY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IT
COSTS THEM FOR THEIR YOU KNOW
FEW SECONDS IN THE GAME TO
ADVERTISE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ELECTRIC CALMER MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT THEY- THAT'S WHERE THEY
THINK THEIR FUTURE IS BUT
WHATEVER IT WAS. THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT THE INDICATES TO ME THAT
THEY BELIEVE THIS ISN'T JUST A
MATTER OF- YOU KNOW DESIRE ON
THEIR PART BUT THEY THINK
THAT'S WHERE THE MARKET IS
GOING ALREADY SO IT'S MORE A
QUESTION I THINK OF WHAT WEEK
AS A STATE OF THAT HAS HIGHWAYS
UNDER OUR JURISDICTION THAT
THAT DOES TAXES THAT DOES A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS WHAT ARE
THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE- I MEAN
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADD SOME
CITIES ARE ALREADY LOOKING AT A
LOS ANGELES I KNOW IS LOOKING
AT TO CREATING ZONES- BY THE
TIME OF THE OLYMPICS COMING TO
LA. ARE YOU COULDN'T GO INTO
THAT AREA WITHOUT ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES SO THERE ARE THERE ARE
OTHER TOOLS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO COMPARE THEM WITH
EACH OTHER- AND SEE WHICH OF
THEM GET A STATE WE NEED TO GET
OUT AS COST EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE. WE JUST. WITH A- LEO
RIVER THAT HAVE COME OUT ABOUT
OUR- OUR PARK AND WHETHER OR
NOT WE'RE GOOD TO MEET OUR-
THIRD GOAL. AND WE HAD THE
TRANSPORTATION ONE THAT'S COME
OUT WE'VE HAD THE ENERGY SECTOR
HAS COME OUT WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF OTHER REPORTS THEM BY.
INDIVIDUAL GROUPS ARE SEPARATE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND
THEY'RE ALL POINTING TO THE
FACT THAT NONE OF THESE THINGS
ARE GOING TO BE MEETING. ARE
TWENTY THIRTY HOLES RIGHT AND
SO WHILE THE MARKET MIGHT BE
SHIFTING AS A SHIFTING QUICKLY
ENOUGH AND IS NOT OUR JOB AS WE
TALK ABOUT CAP AND TRADE OR
CARPET TAX OR ANYTHING ELSE TO
HELP ME TO THE MARKET GETS
THERE BY THE TIME WE NEED IT.
WE SET A GOAL OF TWENTY THIRTY
AND GET AND THAT WHAT WE
THOUGHT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN AT
THE END OF THE CENTURY IS
HAPPENING NOW WITH THAT GOAL
EVEN. WITH THAT TOO FAR AWAY DO
WE NEED MORE IMMEDIATE. ME
IMMEDIATE ACTION NOW AND SO YOU
KNOW I WOULD SAY THAT WE NEED
TO REVISIT WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
CAP AND TRADE IS. A LONG WAY IN
IT JUST TO CAN. THE COSTS
BRENDA. I SHOULD WE BE TALKING
ABOUT SOCIAL COSTS ARE WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO OUR ECONOMY
WE DON'T ACT QUICKLY ENOUGH AND
I THINK FOR MYSELF THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS ADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES
COMMITTEES THAT ARE THE MOST
BIRD AND WHERE HEALTH IS AT
RISK- EVEN MORE EVERY DAY THAT
SENSE OF URGENCY THAT WE THAT
WE HAVE THERE. ON INTO YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT. THE GOAL OF
CAPTAIN TRADING STATED A GOAL
OR TO THEM TO THAT CONTINUE TO
BE OUR GOAL OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE WE NEED TO
BE THIS THAT. I THINK IT'S A-
THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
SCOPE A PLAN THAT WILL TAKE US
TO TWENTY THIRTY. THAT IS A
STATE WHERE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
THE- MISSION OF EVERYONE OF
THE- MEASURES THAT'S INCLUDED
IN THE PLAN IS AND THAT
INCLUDES CAP AND TRADE. AS I
SAID WHEN WE DID THE ORIGINAL.
SCOPING PLAN GOING BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. WE SAW CAP
AND TRADE AS BEING. A WAY TO
PUT A CAP. WHICH WAS THE MOST
IMPORTANT FEATURE TO SAY. HOW
MANY TOTAL EMISSIONS ARE
ALLOWABLE. AND THEN TO CREATE A
CREDIBLE SYSTEM. WHICH INCLUDED
A RECOGNITION OF THE FACT. THAT
OUR OTHER REGULATORY PROGRAMS
WERE GOING TO BE DRIVING DOWN
THE EMISSIONS. SO IT WOULD BE
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR THOSE WHO
HAD TO. HAD TO PAY THE COSTS OF
THE PROGRAM. IT IS IN A SENSE
IT'S IN THIS WAS SO CLEARLY
DISCUSSED WHEN THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB THIRTY
TWO YOU COULD LOOK AT CAP AND
TRADE AS BEING A TYPE OF CARBON
TAX IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT WAY
OF DOING IT WHERE. YOU KNOW THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF ALLOW AND SAYS
AND THE PRICE CAN VERY UNDER.
UNDER A CARBON TAX YOU SAT AT
AMOUNT OF PRICE- H. THàNH OF
CARBON AND- THEN PEOPLE CAN
CHOOSE HOW MUCH OF IT THEY WANT
TO USE. OR NOT. USE AND EITHER
ONE OF THOSE KINDS OF SYSTEMS
HAS PRINT SEVERAL CONSEQUENCES
TO IT. THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IS MORE. INDIRECT
PEOPLE DON'T SEE- AND- THAT
SOMETIMES THAT'S FRUSTRATING TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY ARE
SUBJECT TO THESE PROGRAMS. BUT
THE FACT IS THAT IT'S A THIS IS
A POLICY. CHOICE THAT THAT NEED
TO BE MADE AND I THINK IT'S A I
THINK IT REALLY IS A CHOICE OF
THE- LATER ITSELF NEEDS TO.
NEEDS TO BE DIRECTLY INVOLVED
IN. A I AGREE THAT WE AS LIST
JOURNEY TO BE THIS TEAM WERE
WERE AT WITH. WITH CAPTAIN AND
IF GIVEN THE NEW INFORMATION WE
HAVE AND THAT IS WHERE WE-
CONTINUE ARE NOT I ALWAYS SAW
IT AS- A WAY TO CLOSE THE
DELTA- AND LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENT REPORTS THE YOU KNOW
WE KNOW THAT OUR PS. IS I'VE
HAD A POSITIVE. EFFECT ON OUR
GOALS TOWARDS OUR WILLS ARE. WE
THERE'S A FEW A FEW ITEMS OUT
THERE THAT WE KNOW ARE YOU ARE
YOU LEADING US IN A GOOD
DIRECTION BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THT ARE NOT. ON AND SO
I THINK WE NEED TO REVISIT- CAP
AND TRADE AND IF WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT HOW DO WE- IN.
POSSIBLY CHANGE. ARE THOSE THE
PRICING THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT
IS CHANGING BEHAVIOR AS WELL.
WELL IT AND GET IT I THINK YOU.
MENTIONED THE FACT THAT- WHEN
IT WAS DESIGNED IT WAS NOT
INTENDED AS A REVENUE RAISER I
REALLY WANT TO UNDERSCORE. THAT
POINT. OF THE FACT THAT THERE
WAS A SMALL NUMBER OF
ALLOWANCES THAT THE STATE
DIDN'T JUST. VOLUNTARILY GIVE
TO THE SUBJECT TO THE PARTY
SUBJECT TO IT. WAS A THAT WAS
CONTROVERSY- BUT WE SAID. WE
NEED SOMETHING IN ORDER TO.
BASICALLY BE AND MAKE SURE
THERE'S TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THE
PRICE THAT PEOPLE WILL
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PRICE IS.
AND AS IT TURNED OUT IT RAISED
A- SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
REVENUE WHICH IS THAT WE USE-
IT FOR VERY GOOD PURPOSES AND-
I MEAN I THINK YEAH IT'S BEEN
A- REALLY THAT HAS BEEN A
BRILLIANT SUCCESS. BUT THE
PROGRAM WAS NOT DESIGNED WITH I
WAS ALMOST AN AFTERTHOUGHT.
YEAH NOW AFTER THE THAN I HAD
BECOME AND- THAT. PROGRAM OUT
THERE RIGHT SO DEFINITELY- LET
ME ASK YOU A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
DIRECTION- BUT BUT TIED TO THE
SAME DISCUSSION WHEN WE DID CAP
AND TRADE WITH THAT AB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND YOUR WEAPONS THAT
IN IN YOUR COMMENTS THAT YOUR
EARLIER PART OF YOUR-
PRESENTATION- AND THE GOAL OF.
OF THE OF CARDS YOU KNOW TO
HAVE CLEANER AIR OUT THERE IS
ALL THE OTHER PARTICULAR
MATTERS HE SHOWED US IN THE
FIRST HALF OF YOUR PRESENTATION
BUT IN THE BUDGET- THAT WAS
JUST PRESENTED IN JANUARY BY
THE GOVERNOR. THE COP TO AB
SEVENTEEN OUT THERE AND THE
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING- OTHERS TO CUT TO THE
INCENTIVES FOR CLEAN CARS AND
TRUCKS AND SO IT SEEMS TO BE
KIND OF. COUNTRY TO SOME OF OUR-
AS WE LOOK AT THE PICTURE
HOMELESS. THE HAVE. INPUT ON
THAT OR- COMMENTS. I REALLY
COULD ONLY COMMENT THAT I THINK
THE BUDGET- REPRESENTS THE
BEGINNING OF A CONVERSATION
WHICH I KNOW YOU WILL BE HAVING
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. YEAH
I MEAN. DEFINITELY AS LIZ WE'VE
WE'VE JUST OF FINISH THE FIRST
YOUR PLANS AND WE HAVE SELECTED
THAT MAKES A HANDFUL OF
COMMUNITIES- IT IS A LITTLE
TROUBLING BUT WHEN WE THINK OF
THE GOVERNOR SCHOOL OF JUSTICE
FOR ALL- WELL A. B. C.'S
SEVENTEEN IS AND- BY ALL MEANS
ARE ONLY. TOOL THAT WE NEED IT
IS ONE THAT IS ACTUALLY DRAWING
DOWN TO LOCAL LEVEL FOR MAKING
SURE HAT WE HAVE JUSTICE FOR
ALL. THAT'S SPECIFIC TO A
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY SAYS WE'RE
LOOKING HOLISTICALLY AT THE
SYSTEM WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE SAME EMISSION TRANSIT WE
SORRY ON THAT WE SHOULD BE
REALLY PROUD OF HIS OF THE
STATE. CAN BE FELT BY ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND NOT JUST SOME
CALIFORNIANS. OUT THERE. SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT I- FOR THE
SAKE OF. A SICK INTO MY OWN
TIMELINE. GOING TO GOING TO
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
TO THE LOCAL OVER TO THE
CONTINUED DISCUSSION TO THE
BUDGET TO DO ADDITIONAL
HEARINGS. AND I DIDN'T GET TO
ASK YOU ABOUT OUR TOPICS
RELATED TO THE SECOND PART OF
THE PRESENTATION I DO APOLOGIZE
I SAY JUST REALIZED- I LOST
TRACK OF MY HEALTHCARE- I WAS
SO BUSY WITH CAP AND TRADE IN
AB SIX SEVENTEEN. SO ACTUALLY.
IN THE SECOND HALF WE'RE GOING
TO BE THIS GUY ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS AND I DIDN'T
GET TO ASK ANY OF YOUR OPINIONS
YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION DO
YOU WANT TO TAKE A SECOND TO
SAY ANYTHING WELL WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
HERE AS I MENTIONED WE DID
DEVELOP AN ACCOUNTING PROTOCOL
FOR- CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION PROJECTS AND
WE'RE AWARE NOW THAT DOWN
THERE'S A MOVEMENT TOWARDS
BRINGING FORWARD AT LEAST ONE
PROJECT THAT. WOULD HOPE TO GO
THROUGH THAT KIND OF A NEW
SYSTEM AND WE THINK THAT WILL
BE A BIG INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE
TO LOOK AT OTHER WAYS TO DO IT-
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK GOING ON
THAT SAID- BEING FUNDED BY
FOUNDATIONS AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS WE DON'T HAVE A
BUDGET RELATE TO BE INVOLVED IN
THE RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
AREA THERE BUT WE'RE VERY KEEN
ON- I'M FOLLOWING WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND IF WE CAN FIND
WAYS THAT WE CAN- FURTHER.
INDUCE MORE PEOPLE TO- TO BRING
FORWARD AND EXPAND ON THESE
KINDS OF TECHNOLOGIES WE THINK
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SO WE
WILL BE TRACKING- GHG REDUCTION
SEPARATELY FROM GHG NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS OF WE WILL HAVE THAT
YES. OKAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
IS. THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. FIRST
IN THE.
OKAY I THINK IS THAT WE
HAVE OUR SECOND PANEL. COMING
UP WHERE WE HAVE IMPACTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS OUT INTO
THAT COULD HAVE THOSE PANELISTS
COME UP HERE PLEASE. AND SO TO
THEY WERE HAVE GEORGE PERIOD AS
OFTEN THE LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
NATIONAL LAB. TALKING TO US
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS ARE REACHING OUR
STATE CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS.
LAKE SIMON'S WITH THE DIVISION-
DIRECTOR FOR BIOSCIENCES AT
LAWRENCE. BERKELEY NATIONAL LAB
THAT OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
THAT TO GIVE EMISSIONS OF
CARBON. REMOVAL AND OTHER BIO
BASED STRATEGIES. AND LUCILLE
THAT'S WHERE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNSEL WITH THE ROLE OF
EQUITY IN UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPACTS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE NEGATIVE EMISSIONS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR MAKING TIME
TO BE HERE TODAY TO THE A
PRESENTATIONS AND HELP ANSWER
SOME OF OUR COMMITTEES
QUESTIONS. AND SO WE WILL LET
YOU BEGAN- AND SO WILL HAVE
GEORGE READ AS GO AHEAD TO
START. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE TIMELY INVITATION
TO TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS
GEORGE BURIED US. AND I'M
DELIGHTED TO REPRESENT THE
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE NATIONAL LAB
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN STUDYING THE
TOPIC OF NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
INTENTLY. ON THE LAST WEEK WE
RELEASED A COMPREHENSIVE FIRST
OF ITS KIND REPORT THAT
OUTLINES. REALISTIC PATHWAYS
THAT ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO
ACHIEVE ITS MID CENTURY CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOAL. WE FOUND THAT
BY REMOVING CO TWO FROM THE F.
THE STATE CAN ACHIEVE ITS GOAL
AT A COST THAT IS LESS THAN
WHAT WE CURRENTLY SPENDS TO
MANAGE TRASH. TODAY HUMM EAGER
TO SHED SOME OF A OF THE
DETAILS OF WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED
THE REPORT WAS CO AUTHORED BY
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SCIENTISTS
ACROSS A TO RENOWNED CITIZENS.
AND ORGANIZATIONS AND MADE
POSSIBLE THROUGH THE GENEROSITY
OF THE CLIMATE WORKS FOUNDATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS ESTABLISHED
ITSELF AS AN INDISPUTABLE
LEADER IN CLIMATE CHANGE
TECHNOLOGIES AND POLICIES
GLOBALLY. AND LATELY IS HAS
STEPPED UP ITS AMBITION LEVEL
CONSIDERABLY THROUGH GOVERNOR
BROWN'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THE
CALLS FOR REDUCING EMISSIONS
TWO ZERO. BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
REMOVING CO TWO FROM THE AIR IS
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN BE CERTAIN
TO ACHIEVE THIS FILE GOAL.
DOING SO IS NEITHER A LICENSED
TO CONTINUE POLLUTING. NOR
LUXURY THAT WE CAN DO AWAY
WITH. THE PRECIPICE
UNFORTUNATELY REALLY IS BEFORE
US. AND WE HAVE TO TAKE CAPITOL
STEPS TO REDUCE AND MANAGE OUR
RISK OF FAILURE. WHEN I WAS A
TAKING AVALANCHE TRAINING I WAS
STRUCK BY SOMETHING THAT'S THE
NOLLIE. MOUNTAINEERING RANGER
DAVE WEBER SAID. HE SAID THAT
ALL HOPE IS A HORRIBLE RISK
MANAGEMENT TOOL. AND THE WHEN
WE WERE LONG ON HOPE TO KEEP US
SAFE. WE ARE PROBABLY IN HARM'S
WAY. I AM PROUD TO LIVE IN A
STATE THAT ENABLES ME TO HAVE
SOLAR PANELS ON MY ROOF AND TO
DRIVE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE. BUT
SINCE WE CANNOT CONFIDENTLY
TELL OUR CHILDREN TODAY THAT
OUR EFFORTS TO USE ENERGY MORE
EFFICIENTLY GENERATE POWER FROM
RENEWABLE SOURCES. AND PUT
CLEAN IT BECAUSE ON THE ROAD
ALONE. WILL REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS TWO ZERO BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. WE SIMPLY CANNOT
OPERATE UNDER THE ASSUMPTION
THAT CAR STRATEGIES WILL
SUFFICE. WE MUST ALSO CONSIDER
THAT THE EQUATION FOR REACHING
THAT ZERO MAKE CHANGE AND
REQUIRE AN EVEN BIGGER EFFORT.
IT IS CLEAR THAT'S TO SOLIDIFY
CHANCES OF ACHIEVING THEGOAL
WE MUST THAT IN YOU STRATEGIES
TO THE MIX. THE PHYSICALLY
REMOVE CO TWO FROM THE AT. AND
REPORTS WE SET OURSELVES A
CHALLENGE OF SEEING IF
CALIFORNIA CAN ACHIEVE A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE. MILLION
TONS PER YEAR. OF NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS. USING ONLY
TECHNOLOGIES AND PRACTICES THAT
ARE RIGHT TO BE SCALED UP TODAY.
THIS NUMBER REPRESENTS THE
LEVEL OF RIGID RESIDUAL
EMISSIONS THAT WE REALISTICALLY
EXPECT TO REMAIN BY MID
CENTURY. DESPITE ALL OTHER
MITIGATION EFFORTS. I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT IN GETTING TO
NEUTRAL OPTIONS FOR NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
FIND SAID THAT THE STATE'S CAN
DO THAT'S USING THREE MAIN
APPROACHES. HARNESSING THE
POWER OF MOTHER NATURE. PUTTING
WASTE BIOMASS TO WORK AND
PHYSICALLY SCRUBBING CO TWO
FROM THE AIR. OUR FIRST
APPROACH ENTAILS STORING MORE
COMMON FORESTS WETLANDS
GRASSLANDS AND SOILS. THROUGH
RESTORATION CHANGES TO THE WAY
THE CALIFORNIA MANAGES ITS
NATURAL WORKING LANDS WE COULD
STORE AN ESTIMATED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TONS OF CO TWO PER YEAR
WHILE BENEFITING OUR ADD WATER
AND THE RESILIENCE OF THE
SYSTEMS TO CHANGES IN OUR
CONDITIONS. UNFORTUNATELY
NATURE CAN ONLY DELIVER UP TO A
FIFTH OF THIS TARGET. THE
SECOND LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS AND TELLS
PUTTING CALIFORNIA SUBSTANTIAL
WASTE BY MASS RESOURCES TO WORK
CONVERTING THEM INTO RING YOU
WILL TRANSPORTATION FUELS WHILE
APPARENTLY REMOVING AND STORING
THE CARBON. THE BIOGENIC
PORTION OF URBAN TRASH RESIDUES
FROM AGRICULTURE AND FORCE
THINGS. THAT THE STATE WILL BE
REMOVING FOR FIRE RISK
REDUCTION CAN BE CONFERRED
CONVERTED INTO COMMON NEGATIVE
TRANSPORTATION FUELS. THESE
ALSO IMPROVE OUR QUALITY BOTH
BY DOING AWAY WITH THE CAR IN
PRACTICE OF BURNING WOOD. AND
ALSO BY DISPLACING FOSSIL FUELS
FROM THE WROTE. A REPORT FINDS
OF THE STRATEGY COULD COULD
DELIVER BETWEEN EIGHTY AND
NINETY MILLION TONS OF CO TWO
PER YEAR. OF NEGATIVE EMISSIONS.
FINALLY THE THIRD APPROACH AND
FALSE USING MACHINES A SCRUB CO
TWO FROM THE AD IN A PROCESS
CALLED DIRECT TAKE CAPTURE.
THIS CAN BE APPLIED AND WHETHER
WE HAVE GEOTHERMAL HEAT ON
NATURAL GAS. AND WE CAROLINE
THE STRATEGY TO MAKE AS LARGE.
A CONTRIBUTION TO OUR GOAL AS
WE CHOOSE. NONE OF THESE
STRATEGIES RELYING ON
TECHNOLOGICAL BREAKTHROUGHS
MOST OF THEM ARE READILY
AVAILABLE. AND OTHERS WILL
NEEDS HELP. SIMPLY TO REDUCE
COSTS. THIS MAY SURPRISE YOU
THE NUMBERS WHERE A PLEASANT
SURPRISE TO US THIS COMBINATION
OF APPROACHES IS EASILY
AFFORDABLE AND COSTS RANGE
BETWEEN A FEW DOLLARS PER TONNE
OF CO TWO. AND LESS THAN TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER TONNE OF CO
TWO FOR DIRECT I CAPTURE AFTER
A MODEST AMOUNT. OF LEARNING.
THE TOTAL EXPENDITURE IS LESS
THAN TEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
LESS THAN WHAT CALIFORNIA
SPENDS ON MANAGING ITS TRASH
AND ONLY ZERO POINT FOUR
PERCENTS OF THE STATE'S CURRENT
GDP. YOU MIGHT BE WONDERING
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CARBON THAT
WE REMOVE- THAT ISN'T STORED IN
NATURAL SYSTEMS SYSTEMS WHAT IS
I GO. WELL IT'S GOES RIGHT BACK
WHERE IT CAME FROM IT CAN BE
STORED IN THE SAID IMMENSELY
ROCKS THAT HAVE HELD WATER GAS
AND OIL FOR MILLIONS OF YEARS.
AND WELL WE DUG UP THE CARBON
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
CALIFORNIA'S TRULY BLESSED WITH
EXCEPTIONAL GEOLOGY. AND BASINS
THAT CAN STORE LIQUID CO TWO
SAFELY AND PERMANENTLY. AND WE
ALSO HAVE THE WORLD'S NEWEST
INSTRUCTORS REGULATIONS THAT
GOVERN CO TWO INJECTION. THANKS
TO THE VISION RE EFFORTS AND
THAT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
UNDER CHEN NICHOLS COMPLETED
JUST OVER A YEAR AGO. WHEN IT
COMES TO CLIMATE MITIGATION
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS TOO
MUCH OR TOO FAST. WE NEED ALL
SAFE APPROACHES ON THE TABLE.
THE URGENCY IN MAGNITUDE OF THE
PROBLEM SIMPLY DO NOT AFFORD US
ANY WIGGLE ROOM THE NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS PATHWAYS THAT WE HAD
DONE TO FIND IN A IN THE
REPORTS. A WELL WITHIN THE
STATE'S REACH AND ARE AN
IMPORTANT SUPPLEMENTS TO THE
MITIGATION TOOLS A CALIFORNIA
HAS ALREADY CHAMPIONS. WHAT'S
MORE THESE APPROACHES WILL
CREATE JOBS IN THE STATE WHERE
THEY ARE MOST NEEDED. THEY WERE
DISPLACED ALSO FUELS IT WOULD
HELP CLEAN UP AND WATER AND
THAT WOULD PROTECT LIFE AND
PROPERTY THROUGH WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
STATE HAS REACHED ITS NIKE
MOMENTS AND CLIMB IN MITIGATION
IT IS TIME TO JUST DO IT. AND
SIGNED A TEAM STAND TO HELP-
STAND READY TO HELP IN ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL BE THE NEXT
PRESENTATION I'LL ASK QUESTIONS
AT THE END OF ALL. THANK. HI MY
NAME'S BLAKE SIMMONS- DIVISION
DIRECTOR OF BIOLOGICAL SYSTEMS
AND ENGINEERING AT LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABORATORY.
GET THE SLIDES UP AND- BY
MINUTES. I WILL GIVE YOU A BRO
WHEN HIGH LEVEL TOUR OF A
VARIETY OF PROJECTS THAT. DON'T
FEEL VERY NICELY WITH THE- THE
REST OF THE PRESENTATION THAT
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY. AND SO-
WITH A FOCUS ON THOSE THAT
REALLY ENABLE A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY AND ALSO HAVE THE
POTENTIAL FOR NEGATIVE CARBON
EMISSIONS. AND JUST PUT IT IN
CONTEXT ABOUT THIS NOTION OF A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY- THIS IS A
WASTE NOT WANT NOT- TYPE OF
APPROACH FOR CARBON MANAGEMENT
AND FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH. WHERE
YOU BASICALLY HAVE AN ECONOMY
THAT IS BASED ON MULTIPLE
PASSES OF THE SAME CARBON.
THROUGH ALL OF THE STEPS THAT
YOU SEE HERE OF OUTLINED HERE.
ON THAT CHART ON THE RIGHT- THE
BIO CONNIE IS A PART OF THAT
AND THE BIO COM UNITED STATES
IS ROUGHLY ONE TRILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR NOW. SO IT'S NOT A-
INSIGNIFICANT THING THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE NOTHING ON
THE FRINGES IT IS VERY.
MAINSTREAM AND CALIFORNIA'S AT
THE FOREFRONT OBVIOUSLY OF
LEADING THE WAY TO THE TO PAINT
THE WAY FOR. A CIRCULAR CONNIE
AND- GERMAN NICHOLS POINTED OUT
THESE- SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
THAT COULD BE OPERATING ON THE
CIRCUIT. I MEAN WHERE YOU BASS
HE REVIEWS RE UTILIZE AND RICK.
THE CALIFORNIA CAR RESOURCES
ARE DISTRIBUTED- AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE
UNIQUE GEOGRAPHIC AND NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE STRATEGIC TO
VOTE THE ECONOMY INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT IN THE STATE.
OTHERS ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION BONE DRY TIMES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO CONVERT INTO
SOMETHING. EACH YEAR. AND THE
QUESTION IS NOT WHAT. YOU KNOW
CAN WE MAKE NOT LOOKING FOR A
SILVER BULLET. BUT REALLY
LOOKING AT A PRIORITIZE WAY TO
MANAGE THAT RESOURCE
APPROPRIATELY EFFECTIVELY.
SECOND HAVE THE MAXIMUM BENEFIT
TO THE ECONOMY THE ENVIRONMENT
AND HUMAN HEALTH. BY
MANUFACTURING THIS IS THE VERY
SIMPLE CARTOON OF WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT. IS YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE INPUTS THAT ARE COMING
INTO SOMETHING THAT CAN REPLACE
MANUFACTURING THAT WE KNOW
TODAY IN A CONVENTIONAL SENSE.
AND THESE COULD BE SUGARS THAT
ARE LIBERATED FROM THE MISSILE
AS A BIOMASS TREES GRASSES WHAT
HAVE YOU- THEY CAN BE LINK THEN
FROM THOSE SAME RESOURCES AND
THEY CAN ALSO BE WASTE STREAMS
BE THEY FROM FORESTRY FROM
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING MUNICIPAL
SOLID WASTE. AND THE POINT IS
THAT YOU WANT TO TAKE ALL THESE
CARBON INPUTS AND PUT THEM INTO
AN APPROACH RE CAN GENERATE
MULTIPLE OUTPUT GET OFF OF
EVERY ASPECT PETROLEUM. WHY THE
JOB FOR CHEMICAL COMPANY OR
FUELS AND DO SO IN A
SUSTAINABLE WAY THAT MAXIMIZES
THE IMPACT TO THE ENVIRONMENT
THE HEALTH AND THE ECONOMY. ONE
EIGHT. OF THAT IS TRANSITIONING
OR WAY FROM GREEN GAS SOURCE
THE SINK IN THIS WAS ALLUDED TO
IN THE EARLIER TALK. ABOUT THE
MANAGE AN ACTIVE LANDS THAT THE
PRACTICES AND LAND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES THAT CAN ACTUALLY
GENERATE A CARBON SINK OUT INTO
THESE MANAGE LANDS. AS A WE CAN
INCREASE THE QUANTITY OF BOMB
MASSIVE REQUIRES THIS
MANAGEMENT CONVERSION WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS IN TERM NICHOLS TALK.
BUT ALSO INCREASE THE
GENERATION OF BY PRODUCTS SUCH
AS DIGEST STATES COMPOST AND BY
WHICH ARE. THEY CAN BE USED
WITH THE VANCE PLAN MATTER
PRACTICES THE DRIVE THAT CAR.
FORWARD THE MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFIT AND TRANSFORM WHAT IS
CURRENTLY A POLLUTANT SOURCE OF
CALL IN AND TURN IT INTO A SINK
THAT CAN BE USED TO ENABLE. THE
STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION TARGETS. THE ROLE OF
BIO TURNED JUST SAY THE NET
ECONOMY IS HERE AND THE NUMBERS
ARE. ARE PRETTY IMPRESSIVE BUT
WE COULD OVER TIME BASICALLY
ACCOUNT FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS MEDIC A
EMISSIONS. A IF YOU TAKE IT
OVER SEVERAL DECADES AND SO
THIS IS A VERY. INTERESTING
APPROACH THAT IS CAN BE VERY
EFFECTIVE IN VERY SIMPLE TO
IMPLEMENT. AND DOVETAILS NICELY
WITH THE POLICY REQUIREMENTS OF
YOU WERE EVEN TALKING ABOUT.
THERE'S ALSO THE NOTION INITIAL
SOLID WASTE AS A BIOLOGY
FEEDSTOCK IN SO IN RURAL AND
URBAN AREAS IN PARTICULAR-
THERE IS A LOT OF WAYS THAT IS
GENERATED THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY
BEING. BALLERUP ISN'T ANYTHING
USEFUL FOR. ME TO BENEFIT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND HUMAN HEALTH.
AND SO THERE'S A PROJECT THE
THAT WAS A JOINT ONE BETWEEN I
DON'T NATIONAL LABORATORY
SANDIA NORTH BERKELEY. WHERE WE
DEVELOP TECHNOLOGIES TO DO
BLENDING OF MUNICIPAL SOLID
WASTE STREAMS AND CONVERT THEM
INTO BILE FEELS ABOUT PRODUCTS.
THAT COULD GO INTO THE ECONOMY
AND BE OF NET BENEFIT. TO BOTH
IN. AND HUMAN HEALTH. AS WHEN
HE TAKE A LOOK AT THE FOOD. AND
PAY WAY. I CAN VAL RISE THOSE
ARE. LEASE IN FILE FEELS ABOUT
PRODUCTS AND WON'T. GET INTO
LIKE THE NEED TO BE HERE ON THE
DETAILS WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT
LATER. BUT THESE ARE CURRENT
TECH. THAT WOULD BE THE POINT
OF THE SHOW TERM. THANK YOU
BEEN. BOTH RULE URBAN. ENEMY
JOBS. WITHIN MOMENT IN. THEN
WE'LL THE. INSTITUTE AND A MESS
OF BIOFUELS COMPANY AND IT'S
REALLY FOCUSED ON CONVERTING
WOODY BIOMASS FEEDSTOCKS THEIR
WASTE STREAMS CURRENTLY OR POSE
A RISK TO THE ENVIRONMENT
THROUGH WILD FIRES. AND DEPLOY
A TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS DEVELOPED
AT THE NATIONAL LABS IN
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND TRANSFORM THOSE
WOULD BE BOMBERS RESOURCES IN
THIS CASE AS ALMOND WALLET
BEHIND IN POPLAR. INTO AN
AVIATION BIOFUEL PRECURSOR- AND
SO THAT IT IS A GREAT PROJECT
OF BREAK PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP AND ALSO A STATE
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP. BECAUSE OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE JOINT BIO
IMAGES TO COME FROM THE OFFICE
OF SCIENCE WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY. ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR AND THIS SEIZE THE
FINDINGS ACOSTA SHARE FOR THREE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT
COMMERCIALIZED. TECHNOLOGY OUT
OF THAT THE AMERICAN BUT IT.
END OF ONE VERY EXCITING. THE
JUST GOT A NOW I TODAY A CAL IN
THIS IS FUNDED BY THE C. C. I
G. G. R. F. FUND. IT'S A
DEVELOPMENT OF A MOBILE BUYER
REFINERY THAT HE COULD TAKE OUT
TO ASSIST WITH FIRE CLEARING
OPERATIONS I SHOULD SAY FIRED.
UP FOR STREET FITTING
OPERATIONS WHERE YOU COULD TAKE
THE THING MATERIAL AND THE
RESIDUES THAT GETS GENERATED
THAT ARE CLEARED OUT OF THE
FOREST TO MINIMIZE THE RISK OF
WILDFIRES. AND HAVING THIS
MOBILE PLATFORM THAT CAN HURT
THEM INTO BILE POWER BIO FUELS
AND BIO CHART. AND THIS COULD
MINIMIZE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION BY ABOUT 90% IT'S
SIGNIFICANT SNIFFING THE
IMPROVE THEIR QUALITY BY
ELIMINATING PARTICULATE
EMISSIONS AND CAN BE LOCAL
ECONOMIES BY DEVELOPING THIS
TECHNOLOGY THAT COULD BE
DEPLOYED OUT THERE. AND WITH A
DIRECT LOCAL IF IN SO THIS IS
THE- IS PILOT TERM UP. BOTH THE
DAY THAT THE TECH FEASIBLE BUT
YOU CAN ENVISION A SCENARIO
WHERE DOZENS OF UNITS FOR. WHY.
TONS OF THE BOMB AS THAT
CURRENTLY IS A WELFARE RISK AND
CONVERTED INTO. THAT CAN
BENEFIT ECONOMY AND- HUMAN
HEALTH. THERE'S AN ODD JOB OUR
FOUNDRY WHICH ON REFLECTION
PROGRAMS AND MULTI LAB
PARTNERSHIPS AROUND A BY
MANUFACTURING TO BOLSTER THE
ECONOMY THAT IS ALSO DIRECTLY
OF FUNDED TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY
TO COMMERCIALIZE PRODUCTS.
CERTAINLY THERE'S IS ADVANCED
BY APPEALS ON FILE PARKS
PROCESS DEMONSTRATION IN WHICH
IS ONE OF THESE CATALYSTS THE
ENTERPRISES TO TAKE THAT FIRST
STEP BETWEEN THE LAB INTO THE
ECONOMY. AND AS PROOF POSITIVE
THAT THIS IS LOCATED A BERKELEY
LAB AND IT'S WORKED WITH FORTY
INDUSTRY COLLABORATORS- MOST OF
THEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ITS DIRECTLY
RESULTED IN THE COMMERCIAL
LAUNCH OF NINE PRODUCTS THAT
YOU CAN BUY AT TARGET WALMART
TODAY. AS A THIS IS A ROOM
LISTENING TEMPLE OF A PUBLIC
FOR PARTNERSHIP THAT BOOSTS THE
ME BY DOING DIRECT. WITH
INDUSTRY IN THE RISKY RISK
INVESTMENT FOUND SCALING UP A
PRODUCT IN EXPELLING INTO
DIRECT MARKETING. BY THIS IN A
FIELD WITH IS IN CAN. FOOD
HEALTH AND MEET WITH ME AND I
CAL DERRY. AND ALSO THE
ENVIRONMENT IN OUR CULTURE IN
TERMS OF SOIL THEM IS THAT WE
CAN USE. FOR GROWTH IN THE AXE-
ENFORCEMENT. BUT THAT. I WILL
THEY THANK YOU A I'M SHORT ON
TIME IT'LL TURN OVER TO THE NEW
BAKER. GREAT WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD ACTORS. HI MY
NAME'S LOUISE BUT IT'S WORTH A
I'M NEEDS. DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL- THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL THE COUNCIL COORDINATES
AND WORST COLLABORATIVE LEE
WITH PUBLIC AGENCIES
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. TO ACHIEVE
HEALTHY THRIVING AND EQUITABLE
EQUITABLE AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL. AND SO
WE'RE REALLY WORKING ACROSS ALL
OF OUR AGENCIES TO ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE PUBLIC HEALTH-
AND SUSTAINABILITY GOALS ARE
COUNCIL IS TEN MEMBERS-
INCLUDING SEVEN CABINET
SECRETARIES AND CHAIRED BY KATE
CORD AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
WE DO OUR WORK. A NUMBER OF
WAYS THROUGH- INTEGRATED POLICY
PROGRAMS- TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND CAPACITY BUILDING BUT THEN
ALSO THROUGH A NUMBER OF
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS FUNDED
THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND- INSERT TODAY. I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME
OF THE EXAMPLES HOW WE'RE
PUTTING INTO PRACTICE A FEW OF
THE PRINCIPLE THE PROOF IS.
TALKED. I MEAN I KNOW MEET OUR
GOAL THE CLIENT GOALS. NEGATIVE
MISSION AND THIS REGION CAPTURE
ARE GOING TO BE CRITICS. AND AS
A MINISTRATION WE'VE BEEN VERY
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING- AS
CONSERVATION AND MANAGEMENT AND
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS TO
STORE CARBON TO AVOID THE
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAN THE CONVERSION OF OUR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS. STC
ADMINISTERS THE SUSTAINABLE
ATLANTA CONSERVATION PROGRAM
USING GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND DOLLARS. AND HAS PRESERVED
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
ACRES OF FARM AND RANGE LANDS-
OVER THE FIRST FEW ROUNDS OF
THIS PROGRAM. AND SO THIS WORK
IS HAPPENING AND ALL DIFFERENT
SCALES FROM THE VERY LARGE-
FROM FOREST SCALE RANCH SCALE
DOWN TO A NEIGHBORHOOD AND
COMMUNITY AND PROJECTS SCALE SO
I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT SMALLER SCALE WORK
WHICH I THINK REALLY HELPS TO
IN BED. AND THINK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN PROMOTE NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
ALONG SIDE COMMUNITIES
STAKEHOLDERS AND PEOPLE AND I
THINK YOU'LL SEE SOME OF THESE
IDEA AS ACTUALLY START TO BE
PUT INTO PRACTICE SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITY PROJECT SO WANTED TO
START WITH ONE. OF OUR TO.
CLIMATE IS. TRANSFORM TIMING IN
THESE PER AMP THROUGH THE GREAT.
PRODUCTION FUND MAKES LARGE
INVESTMENTS AT A NEIGHBORHOOD
SCALE ON THE ORDER OF FIVE
GRAMS PER SQUARE MILE OR LESS
INTENT TO MAKE IT IT'S A TRICK.
THAT'S MEANT TO CATTLE. ENGINE
MOST ANISH THREE. POINT IT'S BY
A COMMUNITY RATED THEN AT SOME
IS KEEP CO RATE AND OKAY SO THE
NIKKEI MAY. THINKING WORKS TO.
FORTY BASEMENT AS IN THIS.
CLUED ORBIT URBAN FORESTRY
URBAN FARMING NEW PARK PROJECTS
TREE PLANTING SOIL BUILDING
COMPOSTING ALL FOCUSED ON A LOT
OF NEIGHBORHOODS SCALE BENEFITS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BUT
ALSO THEN STORING CARBON- AND
DOING A NUMBER OF OTHER
BENEFITS. SO I JUST PROVIDE IF
YOU VERY CONCRETE EXAMPLES OF
WHERE THIS IS HAPPENING. SO I
ONE OF OUR FIRST INVESTMENTS IS
IN ONTARIO CALIFORNIA AB. AND
WE'VE INVESTED THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AN INTEGRATED
SET OF PROJECTS IN ONE OF THESE
OBJECTS IS THAT WHERE TAKE OF I
A COMMUNITY GARDEN. I WHICH IS
CREATING A NEIGHBORHOOD SCALE
ON TERRIO CARBON FARM. THIS IS
A CLOSED LOOP ORGANIC PROJECT
THAT'S TURNING NEIGHBORHOOD
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL FOOD
WASTE INTO SOIL COMPOST. THE
COMPOST IS THEN BEING FED BACK
INTO THE PROJECT AREA- FOR
COMMUNITY AND HOUSEHOLD GARDENS
FARMS AND IRVING GREENING AND
HAVE A HOUSING PROJECT THAT IS
FUNDED THROUGH THIS PROJECT. IS
USING THE COMPOST IT WILL BE.
OUT DIRECTLY FOR THEIR
LANDSCAPING USES- THIS PROJECT
THE RID RID ABOUT TWENTY FIVE A
TWENTY FIVE HAD MILLION METRIC
TONS OF CO. OVER THE LIFE CYCLE
OF THE PROJECT BUT YOU SEE
CENSUS ABOUT TEN FOR OF THE
AMERICAN RED. THROUGH THAT LAW
SCALE. INVEST IN THE READ. I
SIMILAR AND FRESNO WE'VE GOT
OTHER LARGE TO. INVEST AT I
FRESNO MINISTRY IS BUILDING A
CAR AND FAR THAT WILL PROMOTE
TECHNI SUCH AS TO. NOW MCKAY
AND NOSE SPRAY GROW METHOD TO
PROMOTE. STORAGE IN
SEQUESTRATION WATER
CONSERVATION AND OF COURSE
PROTECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND WHAT'S THE WHAT'S LABOR
COMMUNITY ACTION COMMITTEE IS
COLLECTING FOOD WASTE AND
OTHER- AND WILL REDISTRIBUTE
COMPOST TO RESIDENTS OR DIVERT
IT TO LOCAL FARMS- AND SO ALL
OF THIS AGAIN TAKING WASTE FROM
THE COMMUNITY AND DEVELOPING A
SYSTEM TO GET IT BACK OUT AND
USE IN THE COMMUNITY SO TRYING
TO CREATE A CLOSED LOOP SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION IN WHAT'S WERE
PLANNING OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED STREETS ON CITY
STREETS- AND ESTABLISHING FIFTY
MANY URBAN FARMS- ON
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES TO HELP
JUST AGAIN USED FOR THE COMPLEX
BUT ALSO DISTRIBUTING THIS TYPE
OF FIVE CARBON STORY
OPPORTUNITY AT DIFFERENT SKIN
AND SO AGAIN IN THIS IN THIS
WHAT'S PROJECT WHERE WE'VE
INVESTED MADE A LARGE SCALE
INVESTMENT IN INTEGRATED SET OF
PROJECTS. ABOUT ONE SEVENTH OF
THE TOTAL CARBON REDUCTION
WE'RE EXPECTING THROUGH THAT
PROJECT- IS COMING FROM THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS- WE ALSO LOOK
AT THIS AT A PROJECT LEVEL
SCALES WHEN WE'RE MAKING
INVESTMENTS THROUGH THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE. BEAUTIES PROGRAM
WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT
SUPPORTS INTEGRATED HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA- AND REALLY
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
MAKING LAND USE AND INVESTMENT
DECISIONS- TO BRING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- TO JOB- AND OTHER
DESTINATIONS ARE REALLY LOOKING
WITH A FOCUS ON HOW TO. REDUCE
DRIVING BUT A LONG SET DOING
THAT HOW WE CONTINUE TO PROMOTE
URBAN GREENING AND SO WE
REQUIRE URBAN GREEN. FOR ALL
PRIVATE. SCHOOLS SEE AT LEAST
TO READING PROJECT A PART OF
FIVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROJECT. AND HAVE INCENTIVE
POINTS- TO ENCOURAGE ADDITIONAL
WORK AND SO A FEW EXAMPLES THAT
WE'VE SEEN HERE- IS IN
MANCHESTER- MANCHESTER URBAN
HOMES IN LA. IT'S GOING TO BE
INSTALLING A GREEN ALLEY AND
THE GARDEN- BLACKSTONE MCKINLEY
ANOTHER PROJECT THAT IS IN
FRESNO- IS DOING AB. STREET
TREES THAT NOT ONLY CAPTURE
CARBON BETTER PROVIDING A
REALLY IMPORTANT URBAN HEAT
ISLAND AND HEAT MITIGATING
EFFECT- AND THEN IN THE CITY OF
COACHELLA WHERE WE'VE JUST
RECENTLY FUNDED A PROJECT.
THERE STRATEGICALLY PLANTED
TREES NEAR A NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO REDUCE
UP TRICKLE OF BLOOD- AND THEN
ALSO ENABLE THAT PROJECT TO RID
RID TO REACHES ZERO NET ENERGY.
AND THEN OF COURSE REDUCING
LOCAL HER HEAT I. WELL I. IN
CARBON AND I NOTE. ONLY USING
OTHER IT UP. IT ALSO WRITTEN
INTO. EXIT CAN START TO SEE
SOME OF THESE PRACTICES BEING
PUT IN ITS OF NEIGHBOR. AND
PRIDE. AS IS OFF SO. REESE TO
ADVANCE NEGATIVE EMISSION
PRACTICES AS PART OF OUR LARGER
CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH
PROGRAM- AND I'M HAPPY I DON'T
NEED TO GO INTO A LOT OF DETAIL
IN THE- INTEREST OF TIME. BUT
ONE THING I DID WANT TO
EMPHASIZE ON THIS PROGRAM IS
IT'S A VERY UNIQUE RESEARCH
PROGRAM THAT IS GROUNDED AND
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT AND SO WE
REQUIRE EVERY FUNDED RESEARCH
PROJECT- TO HAVE A PARTNERSHIP
AS PART. OF THE DESIGN OF THE
RESEARCH THE CONTACT AND THE
ULTIMATE DISSEMINATION. OF THE
RESEARCH PRODUCT THE INTENTION
HERE IS TO ENSURE. THAT WE ARE
IN TING IN RESEARCH IT IS A
THING SOLUTION PROCESSES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE GOING TO
BE USED AND PUT INTO PRACTICE
AND SEE PART SHIP. IN UP BUT RE.
COMMUNITY GROUP. ARM BORIS MAN
IT AND SPELL CLASS YOU SHOULD
THAT CAN TO SO. LIKE PART OF.
MEMBERS OKAY I'LL I'LL- MR
SENATE ALLEN HERE IS THAT THE
ONE PROJECT YOU MENTION LOS AND
JUST CAN YOU TELL ME WHERE IT
IS AND KEEP GIVE A LOT MORE
DETAIL ABOUT IT THE PROJECT IN
WATSON IS THAT THE ONE THAT WAS
NOW WE HAVE WE HAVE SEVERAL IN
LA- SO THERE'S- MANCHESTER
HOMES WHICH IS AT DOT NET
ESTHER OKAY- AND THEN.
TRANSCRIPT I'M A COMMUNITIES
INVESTMENT IS- FOCUS GENERALLY
AROUND THE JORDAN DOWNS
HOUSING. DEVELOPMENT AND IT'S-
CONTRIBUTING WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF AND THAT'S THE ONE THAT YOU
DO WITH THE WHAT CENTER OR-
YES. SO THAT IS AND THAT HAS
THEY ACTUALLY OF SEVERAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY GRANTS
AND THEN A LARGE TCC GRANT THAT
IS FUNDING- THE URBAN FARMING
THAT I SPOKE ABOUT AND
COMPOSTING THE STREET TREES. A
LOT OF LOCAL WEATHER IS ATION-
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENTS. AS WELL AS
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS AND
ADDITIONAL HOUSING PROJECTS
THANK YOU. THE DIRECTOR.
SENATOR MINING THANK YOU ****
ON YOUR WORK IN PRESENTATIONS
FOR MISTER. AS SOME. YOU SPEAK
WITH GREAT CONFIDENCE ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO REMOVE. CARBON
EMISSIONS FROM. WHAT STANDS
BETWEEN US IN DOING THAT IN IS
IT HAPPENING OR WHAT ARE THE
STEPS TIME MAKING IT
OPERATIONAL. SO AS I DIDN'T PUT
UP THE COSCO BUT YOU'LL SEE THE
MOST THINGS LIE IN THE SIXTY IS
DOLLAR- PER TONNE OF CO TWO.
PRICE TAG DIRECT TACK AT
DURATEC CAPS AFTER SOME
LEARNING WILL BE SOMEWHERE
AROUND TWO HUNDRED WE ESTIMATE
MODEST AMOUNT OF LEARNING- WHAT
STANDS IN BETWEEN WELL ONE IS
THE REALIZATION THAT THE STATE
HAS A AN EXPLICIT DIRECTION. TO
MOVE TOWARDS MISSION TO
COLLEGES. I THINK COMPARING
THOSE. PRICE TAGS WITH CURRENTS
LCF ESCORTED PRICES YOU'LL SEE
THAT MOST WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE
IT DOES THAT MEAN THAT A
PROJECT IS FINANCE A BOWL
PERHAPSPERHAPS NOT NOTHING ONE
OF THE- ISSUES SWUNG THE-
RECURRING. WHEN WE TALK TO
DEVELOP IS THAT YOU NEED TO
HAVE A SECURE. SUPPLY OF BY
MASS YOU CAN JUST SAY YOU I'M
GONNA. GET A LITTLE BIT FROM
THIS FARMER A LITTLE BIT FROM
THE FROM CALIFORNIA YOU NEED TO
PROVE THAT YOU HAVE A STEADY
SUPPLY OVER THE LIFE OF. AND
THE FINAL THING THAT WOULD SAY
IS COORDINATION AND PERMITTING.
YOU BRING TOGETHER. FAMILIES OF
ACTIVITIES THAT'S- COME UNDER
EXISTING AUTHORITIES IN
JURISDICTIONS BUT HAVE NEVER
BEEN ATTEMPTED. TO BE BONDED
TOGETHER AS A AS A UNIQUE CHAIN
SO YOU NEED TO. PERMITS WOULD
ADD DISTRICTS WITH THE US EPA
FOR THE INJECTION WHILE WITH
CITIES WITH COUNTIES WITH-
POSSIBLY STATE LANDS COMMISSION
IF YOU GONNA BE BUILDING A
PIPELINE SO IT'S A IT'S A
CONVOLUTED. REGULATORY PICTURE
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE
LOOKED AT IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
HAVE YOU DONE ANY MODELING ON
OUR CURRENT CAP AND TRADE
GETTING US THERE VERSUS. A
CARBON TAX OR OTHER MEANS OF.
MAKING THIS PENCIL OUT IN AGAIN
KEEPING IN MIND THE URGENCY. OF
THE CRISIS WE CAN'T WORK
BACKWARDS AND SAY WE DIDN'T GET
IT RIGHT WE CAN NEED TO GET IT
RIGHT SKINNER RATHER THAN
LATER. YEAH WE FULLY SECOND THE
IN THAT SENSE OF AND- SO MOST
OF THE- IF YOU SEE THE BIG
PILLOW WAS. TURNING BY
MESSENGER FUELS TRANSPORTATION
FUELS SO ADD WASTE- FITTINGS
FROM FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS.
AND THE GREEN PORTION OF THE BY
JENNY PORTION OF TRASH
MUNICIPAL SOLID WASTE. THE BEST
THING TO DO WITH THOSE IS.
MOSTLY TO TURN THEM INTO
TRANSPORTATION FUELS NOT TO
GENERATE ELECTRICITY SO THE
NATURAL MATCH OF POLICY
INSTRUMENT THE CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HOUSE IS THE LOW CARBON
FUEL SAN. AND THIS IS THE OF
THE HIGH VALUE PROPOSITION
RIGHT NOW FOR DEVELOPERS AND IT
ALSO HAPPENS TO BE WHERE THE-
THE MOST STUBBORN SOME OF THE
MOST AUBURN EMISSIONS HAPPEN
TO. TWO WEEKS SO WE THINK THAT
THIS IS THE BEST USE FOR THAT
RESOURCE. THANK YOU. SO I HAVE
A NUMBER OF A QUESTION FOR THE
FOR THE FIRST ONE IS. ARE WE
LOOKING AT. NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
AFTER COMPLIMENTS OR AS A
REPLACEMENT TO SOME OF OUR
REDUCTION POLICIES WE HAVE NOW
YES MISTER PRESS NO ABSOLUTELY
AS A COMPLIMENTS WE NEED TO GO
FLAT OUT ON ALL THE ON GOING
MITIGATION EFFORTS AND AS MISS
JANET GOALS OUTLINED WE NEED TO
COME UP WITH NEW WAYS TO
ACCELERATE AND DEEPENED THOSE
MITIGATION EFFORTS. THE
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS AT SOME OF
THE WE PRESENT OUR WHAT WE
THINK WILL BE NEEDED ON TOP SO
THIS IS BY NO MEANS SETTLED THE
CHECK THE CLOSE THE DOW IS WHAT
WITH LOOKING JUST TO BE CLEAR
HELLO FOLKS GET OURSELVES HERE
NATALIE. THANK YOU SO THEN THE
OTHER PART ABOUT YOUR REPORT
TALKS ABOUT THE COOL BENEFITS
TO OUR QUALITY OUT THERE WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
LOOKING OUT FOR A LONG TIME I
LIVE. UP IN I LIVE IN ONE OF
THOSE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHERE I'M- 5% MOST POLLUTED
ERA. OF THE- OF THE STATE AND I
HAVE THE LUXURY OF MY OPEN
SPACES THE RIVER BED THAT'S OF
CONCRETE JUNGLE NEXT TO THE
FREEWAY. I'M NOT ALWAYS SURE
GOING FOR A WALK IS THE
HEALTHIEST FOR ME EVEN THOUGH I
NEVER SEEM TO GET ENOUGH THAT
SENT. TO MAKE HERE AND SO CAN
YOU QUE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
TASTE IS THAT. WHAT BY THAT. IN
THE I GET THIS CALL THE- NO
IT'S THIS POINTS BUT WE SEE THE
VERY CLEARLY THE- BIO FUELS WE
CREATE FROM THE WAIST BY MASS
WOULD REPLACE FOSSIL FUELS ON
THE ROAD SO IF YOU'RE REPLACING.
DIESEL FOSSEL THE WITH
HYDROGEN. THERE'S AN IMMEDIATE
EQUITY BENEFIT THE ROAD FROM
HEAVY TRUCKING. IF WE CAN DO
AWAY WITH THE PRACTICE OF
BURNING WOODS WHICH HAPPENS IN
BOTH AGRICULTURAL AREAS BUT
ALSO AS A RESULT OF. EITHER
INTENTIONAL OR A WILDFIRE THAN.
WE'VE SEEN WHAT THOSE DAYS CAN
ACTUALLY DO IN IN THE FALL FIVE
SEASON IF WE CAN TAKE THAT.
THAT BURNING AWAY TO SOME
EXTENT AND STERN AND TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUELS AGAIN WE
SEE A DIRECT BENEFIT.
SYLLABUSES BE TRUE WERE
DISABILITIES. WOULD BE LOCATED
IN THESE COMMUNITIES THEY ALSO
SEE. IMPROVEMENTS ARE WHERE
THEY CONTINUE TO. MAYBE WILL
CONTINUE TO CARRY AN UNDUE
BURDEN FOR THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
ABSOLUTELY SO THE HAVE THE BY A
CONVERSION FACILITIES THAT WE
HAVE TALKING OF BEEN NO
RELATION TO THE- BIOMASS PLANTS
OF THE PAST THE WE'VE COME TO
KNOW ALL TOO WELL IN WHICH
BECAUSE A- VERY MARKET IMPACT
ON ON THAT QUALITY. THIS IS A
COMPLETELY NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT
DOES NOT SUFFER FROM THE- FROM
THE SAME POLLUTION PROBLEMS AND
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT. A
GENERATION OF PLANTS THAT HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THIS. SO
YOU WOULD EXPECT SEE YOU EXPECT
THAT WE WOULD HAVE. SEEN OUR IN
DC DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
WIDE THAT COOL BENEFITS
EXPECTED. BUT WE DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE YET I THOUGHT BECAUSE WHEN
WE DID AB THIRTY TWO. WE SAID
THAT WE WERE GONNA GET CLEANER
AIR AND TEN YEARS LATER WE SAW
THAT THAT WASN'T TRUE AND SO
WHAT WE ACCEPT A LOT OF GREAT
CALL BENEFITS. THIS WEBER FELT
IT COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE- BUT
WE WERE WE ALL PAY INTO THE
SYSTEM ON AND SO I JUST AMONG
ALL THE LITTLE HAS A TEN OF
ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE NOT
QUANTIFIED. RELEASES THIS
ADVICE COMMUNITIES OUT THERE.
SO IT WOULDN'T LOOK NO ANALYSIS
THE ERROR THE WOODS. IMPROVED
OUR A FREEWAYS SO HEAVY ROADS
TRY. AND PASSENGER CARS. AND
ALSO AREAS WHERE FARMING IS
PREVALENT SO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. WOULD BE A DIRECT BEEN
OFFICIALLY IN THESE HAPPEN TO
COINCIDE. PRETTY WELL WITH THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND FROM THE PILOTS AYE AYE A
MAYBE MY KNOWLEDGE IS LIMITED
BUT I'VE I'VE LOOKED INTO THE
CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION AT DIFFERENT
TIMES AND WE'VE HAD DIFFERENT
SMALLER SCALE PILOTS BUT WHERE
I'VE SEEN IT HAS I'VE SEEN IT
IN CONJUNCTION WITH. BILL AND
HAS BEEN OF RECOVERY AND WHICH
SEEMS TO BE CONTRARY TO WHAT WE
WANT TO FOUR FOUR ARTICLES
HERE. ON AND SO. IS SCALABLE IT
HAD AND CAN WE AFFORD THIS IS
IT SEEMS TO BE REALLY EXPENSIVE
TO GO DOWN THIS ROAD AND SO I
THINK THOSE BACK TO MR MUNNINGS
QUESTION JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. YOU KNOW HOT. HOW DO WE
GET THERE HOW DO WE PAY FOR IT.
YES SO THIS IS BY NO MEANS
PREDICATED ON ANY REVENUES FROM
INJECTING CO TWO AND GETTING
ADDITIONAL ALLOWS. THE CAPACITY
ESTIMATES THAT WE PRODUCED IN
OUR REPORT. THE SOLELY AND
ROCKS- INDEPENDENT OF ANY OIL
GAS PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN BLESSED WITH IN A
TRULY EXCEPTIONAL. DEEP YOUNG
BASINS THAT OF. THE RIGHT
PROPERTIES TO TRAVEL CO TWO AND
A LOT OF SPACE MANY CENTURIES
WORTH OF SPACE. TO KEEP ITS AND
ACTUALLY THE- TRANSPORTATION AN
INJECTION COSTS IS A IS A VERY
SMALL FRACTION. OF THE TOTAL
WITH THE WITH THE REAL
EXPENDITURES WAS REQUIRED AS
AND BUILDING THE BY MASS
CONVERSION PLANTS NOT.
TRANSPORTING THE CO TWO ASTORIA.
THERE. OKAY WELL THEN IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU GUYS HAVE WORKED
REALLY HARD WITH ME THANK YOU
TO GET A START AT THIRTY FIVE
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN OZ SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR TODAY'S DISCUSSION I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE ONGOING
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE DIRECTION
WE MOVE IN IS AND ALWAYS CARE
BUT THE SENSE OF URGENCY AT
THINK IT'S CLEAR TO ALL OF US
IN THE FACT THAT WE NEED TO BE
CREATIVE AND HAVE A HOLD. OF A
SUITE OF ITEMS THAT WE LOOK AT-
ALONG THE WAY WITH REDUCTIONS-
BEING OUR ULTIMATE GOAL HERE SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU
WE WILL BE HAVING A SERIES OF
HERE HE'S HEARINGS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR THAT WILL BE LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT TOPICS ALL THANK
YOU PUBLIC COMMENT ON. I THINK.
COMMENT I APOLOGIZE. YOU HAVE
ALL THE TIME YOU NEED DON'T
COLLECT AND I NEED TO CUT YOU
OFF I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
BEING. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO THE
AYE LEVIN WITH THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
HOLDING THE HEARING AND THE-
PANELISTS FOR THE GREAT WORK
THAT THEY'RE ALL DOING. IT
MIGHT COME AS A SURPRISE
REPRESENTING THE BUYER WINTERS
HE SAYS HE'S IN CALIFORNIA BUT
I JUST WANNA SAY UP FRONT THERE
ARE GOOD AND BAD PROJECTS. INTO
YOUR QUESTION MADAM CHAIR. AND
THERE ARE WAYS THAT BIOENERGY
CAN PROVIDE MUCH GREATER
BENEFITS FOR AIR QUALITY AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO GET TO THE
HUNDRED ARE SORRY EIGHTY THREE
MILLION METRIC TONS THAT MISTER
PERRY DOS TALKED ABOUT THE BIO
ENERGY. CAN PROVIDING CARBON
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS. WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON COMMUNITY SCALE
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY BIOENERGY
THAT'S ONLY USING ORGANIC WASTE
WE SHOULD BE GROWING FOOD.
CROPS THE PURPOSE OF ENERGY
PRODUCTION WE SHOULD BE TAKING.
HELP THREE. BREAST PRODUCTION.
WE HAVE MORE THAN ENOUGH WASTE
THEY WERE EITHER BURNING OR
LAND NOW THAT CAN BE USED FOR
ENERGY WE ALSO SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON COMMUNITY SCALE
FACILITIES THERE'S NO REASON TO
HAVE ENORMOUS UTILITY SCALE
FACILITIES THAT REQUIRE
TRANSPORTING ORGANIC WASTE OVER
LONG DISTANCES USUALLY WITH
DIESEL POWERED TRUCKS- AND
FINALLY WE SHOULD BE USING
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
COMBUSTION BURNING LOGS SHOULD
HAVE GONE OUT WITH CAVEMEN WE
HAVE MORE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
IN USE IN CALIFORNIA NOW SO IF
IT'S FOOD WASTE TO PROCESSING
WAY STARING THE NEWER WE SHOULD
BE USING ANAEROBIC DIGESTION
WHICH ALSO CAN PRODUCE DIGEST
DATE. WHICH CREATES THE HIGHES
VALUE CLEANEST COMPOST
AVAILABLE IF IT'S WOODY WASTE
REMOVED FOR WILDFIRE REDUCTION
OR AGRICULTURAL WASTE WALNUT
SHELLS THINGS THAT HAVE NO
OTHER ALTERNATIVE VALUE OR THE
WOOD WASTE CURRENTLY GOING TO
LANDFILLS WE CAN GAS OF AYE IT
AND PRODUCE BOTH ENERGY AND BIO
CHAR WHICH CAN PROVIDE
PERMANENT CARBON SEQUESTRATION
THESE ARE MUCH CLEANER MORE
EFFICIENT TECHNOLOGIES WITH A
LOT OF BENEFICIAL BY PRODUCTS
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO MOVE TO
DO THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SMALL SCALE
BY WHAT SHE PROGRAMS IS THE BIO
MAT PROGRAM WHICH WAS CREATE A
STATE LET'S JUST TEN SB. ELEVEN
TWENTY TWO. IT REQUIRES TO
FIFTY MEGAWATT. SMALL BY
WINNERS FACILITIES BUT
CALIFORNIA'S TECHNICALLY
AVAILABLE ORGANIC WASTE COULD
BE PRODUCING FIVE TO SIX
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS. OF NEW
SMALL SCALE BIOENERGY SO WE
NEED TO INCREASE THAT.
REQUIREMENT AND WE NEED TO
SPREAD IT NOT JUST AMONG THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES BUT
SINCE MORE MORE OF OUR
ELECTRICITY IS COMING FROM
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATORS.
AND PUBLIC UTILITIES ALL
ELECTRIC SERVICE PROVIDER
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO SHARE IN
THAT PROGRAM. AND WE NEED TO
ACCELERATE INTERCONNECTION IT'S
WAY TOO HARD TO GET NEW
BIOENERGY EVEN SMALL SCALE
BIOENERGY. THAT'S CRITICAL EVEN
UTILITIES IS THAT IT'S CRITICAL
TO MAKE MICROGRAPHS MORE
RESILIENT AND LONGER DURATION.
WE HAVE TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
PUT IT IN THE PIPELINE AND ON
THE TRANSMISSION LINES IT TAKES
YEARS TO CONNECT THESE NEW
SMALL SCALE BIOENERGY PROJECTS.
TO THE ELECTRICITY GRID ON THE
PIPELINE GRIT. AND WE SHOULD BE
PUTTING MORE FUNDING INTO THESE
PROGRAMS. AND THERE IS JUST NO
WHERE NEAR ENOUGH FUNDING
CONSIDERING THESE ARE NOT ONLY
CRITICAL TO ACHIEVE OUR
CHEMICALS BUT ACCORDING TO THE
LA THEY'RE ALSO THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS. AS MANY.
OF ANY OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDED PROGRAMS. THE
BIO ENERGY RELATED PROGRAMS ARE
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE ON
AVERAGE INTENT. COST OF ALL
TIME. I THE STATE. SO THEY MAY
FROM EVERY SEMI THE LAST THING
I WANT TO MENTION IS COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE I KNOW THAT'S A BIG
TOPIC THIS YEAR AND- THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN FOR YOUR-
LEGISLATION- ON BOND. WINNER
GEE IF IT'S LOCAL ORGANIC WASTE
GOING TO LOCAL ENERGY SUPPLIES
CAN REALLY REAL INCREASE LOW
COMMITTEE RE. AND PROVIDE
THIRTY WITH NOT A LEVEL NGUYEN.
RIGHTS SO NEED TO IT. IN NEW.
BASS TECHNOLOGY BY GENERATE
THANK YOU.BOB I AND STILL JUST
AS YOU'D BE MY- COLLEAGUES
BEHIND THE- THANK YOU. WE HAVE.
PORTABLE ALL THE THAT ARE BEING
A PILOT IT RIGHT NOW ALL THE
RESEARCH IS BEING DONE- MOBILE
SCALABLE- BIO ENERGY THAT CAN
CREATE AND SEQUESTER BIO CHAR
IN THE FOREST ON THE AG LANDS
AND EVEN YOUR LANDFILLS IS
AVAILABLE TODAY THERE ARE FIVE
EXISTING PROJECTS UNDER THE NET
ENERGY NET ENERGY METERING
PROGRAM AT THE P. YOU SEE. YOU
CAN DEVELOP MORE THROUGH BIO
MAT DO MORE THROUGH THERE YOU
CAN EXPEDITE CITING BY USING
THE NAM PROGRAM BUT WE NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT ALL OF THESE
SOLUTIONS AND AGAIN BALANCING
AS CHAIR NICHOLS POINTED OUT
THE HEALTHIER ARE NATURAL-
WORKING IN THE WILD WORKING
LANDS ARE THEY HEALTHY OR WILL
BE IN CITIES AND ELSEWHERE TO
THAT REDUCING THE THERE WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH OF THOSE
LANDS THE PROJECTS ARE WHAT
WHAT DOES THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
HERE TODAY. WE JUST NEED TO
KEEP. THIS KATHY VAN AUSTIN I
REPRESENT UNITED AIRLINES AND-
REALLY APPRECIATED HEARING- THE
COMMENTS TODAY IT HELPS US
KNOW. WHERE WE'VE COME FROM HOW
FAR WE'VE GONE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. AND A TODAY'S. WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM ME AS AN
INDUSTRY THAT HUSBAND SO FAR
AND TAPPED IN THE G. H.
EMISSION REDUCTIONS DISCUSSION-
THE COMMERCIAL AVIATION
INDUSTRY. OF FEDERALLY
REGULATED THEY JUST HAVE NOT
BEEN CONSIDERED- AS A STATUS
DEVELOPED ITS POLICIES WE HAVE
A COALITION OF AIRLINES
AIRPORTS RENEWABLE FUELS
COALITIONS I'M UC DAVIS- A FEW
OR AVENUE SUSTAINABLE AVIATION
FUEL PRODUCERS. WHO WANT TO
COME TO LEGISLATURE
COLLECTIVELY- SHOW YOU WHAT
WE'VE BEEN UP TO WHICH IS A
UNITED HAS BEEN FLYING ON A
SUSTAINABLE AVIATION FUEL FOR
ABOUT FOUR YEARS NOW OUT OF LA
ACTS- THERE'S GREAT DEMAND
AMONG THE AIRLINES FOR THOSE
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
TRULY CONTRIBUTE. TO THE ACTION
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WE
CAN DO GROUND MEANT. WE CAN
REPLACE THAT WE CAN DO THE
SHUTTLE BUSES WHICH CARB JUST
REQUIRE LAST YEAR. BUT THAT
PALES PERSON AS TO WHAT
INDUSTRY CAN DO USING. ESSAY
OFF SO WE WILL BE COMING TO
EACH YOU TO MEET WITH YOU AND
WITH A THE NEXT OF WEEKS. TO
TALK ABOUT THOSE TO TALK ABOUT.
KIND OF PART WE LIKE TO SEE
WITH THE STAY WE THINK THAT BY
TWENTY FIFTY OUR GOAL IS TO
REDUCE OUR GHG EMISSIONS BY
FIFTY PERCENT- TO DO THAT WE
NEED THIRTY FIVE NEW.
PRODUCTION FACILITIES IN THE
STATE WELL IN THE STATE OR
ELSEWHERE WE'D LIKE TO SEE IN
THE STATE BECAUSE WE LIKE THE
JOBS COME HERE- BUT IT'S AN
EXCITING DISCUSSION WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE IT. AND WE'RE EAGER TO
WORK WITH YOU SO WE'LL LOOK FOR
TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EVAN EDGAR
ENGINEER FOR THAT CALIFORNIA
COMPOST COALITION. PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE COMPASS COLLISION AS
WELL AS THE FLEET. WE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO COLLECT THE GARBAGE.
WE HAVE THE TONS OF URBAN WASTE
FOR SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
RIGHT NOW. WE ARE MAKING
CARBONATED A FUEL. LINE AND ONE
OF MY FACILITIES I GOT FIVE
MORE COME ONLINE SO WE'RE
MAKING CARBON AND THEY GIVE
COVERED FIELD TODAY. USE AND
THE CARD PATHWAY. PLUS YOUR NET
ZERO TODAY UNDER THE CARDS
COPING PLAN TO THE REFUSE
INDUSTRY. DON LANDFILLS. WE
COLLECT THE GARBAGE IN ORGANICS.
AT THE AT THE CURB WE TAKE TO
PROCESSING. MAKE ARE MINIMAL
NATURAL GAS MAKE COMPOST AND WE
CALL IT BACK TO THE FIELD. ALL
THAT CAN BE DONE WITH THE
ORANGE WE MAKE SO WE ARE THE
CLOSED LOOP SUBCIRCULAR ECONOMY
TODAY. AND WHEN WE HALL THE
FUEL AROUND WITH A CUST THE
CARBON AND BY WITH HER BACK TO
THE SOIL. SO THE REFUSE
INDUSTRY THE COUPLE'S
COALITION. OR ABOUT BIG SOIL
NOT BIG OIL. THAT'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE. OR GET OFF DIESEL
WE'LL GET OFF LANDFILLS. WE'RE
DOING IT TODAY WITH SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WITH TECHNOLOGY
TODAY. WHETHER WE GOT TO
PRESERVE IS ARE NEAR ZERO
KNOCKS FLEET BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
IN ORDER TO USE OUR ORANGEY. OR
NEAR ZERO WITH KNOCKS. TODAY
WERE PRESERVED- REDUCING
KNOCKS. I GET OFF DIESEL BY
GOING TO THE COMINGS WESTPORT
ENGINE. FOR USE THAT IN STATE
ORANGEY GAS WAS CARBONATED F.
EVER MAKE IT OR- COM. WITH IN
NEW JERSEY PASSES AGO BACK TO
THE ALL. SO WE ARE SICK. BIG
CAR. WE NEED A PRESERVE THE-
FLEET NEEDS TO PRESERVE NEAR
ZERO. IN ORDER TO KEEP ALL
COLLECTED ORGANICS. NEAR ZERO
MINUTE. NOT AND HE- GREENHOUSE
REDUCTIONS THOSE CAR TODAY.
WHERE DO NETWORK THE LOOP. AND
WE'RE GOING BACK TO TWENTY
THREE CALLS THE POLICE PRESERVE
THE REST IS FULLY NEAR ZERO
KNOCKS TRUCKS. THANK YOU. THANK
HIGH THEIR BODY BY OLD AGAINST.
I THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY THE PRESENTATION
HIGHLIGHTED SOME USEFUL FORMS
OF BIOMASS RECYCLING THE JUST
COMPOSTING AN ANAEROBIC
DIGESTION- THE OFFER HUGE
BENEFITS FOR BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE ECONOMY
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT THESE PREVENTIVE
KNOWLEDGE USE ARE BEING
CONFLATED USE OF MUNICIPAL.
SOLID WASTE AS FUEL- FOR SO
CALLED CONVERSION TECHNOLOGIES
ARE THIS IS NOT A RENEWABLE
SOURCE OF ENERGY GIVEN THE HIGH
FRACTION OF FOSSIL FUEL DERIVED
PLASTICS IN THE WASTE STREAM
ADDITIONALLY LIFECYCLE ANALYSES
HOW FOR NEARLY ALL MATERIALS
SHOW THAT THE SIGNIFICANT- AND
SAVINGS RECYCLING MATERIAL.
FIRST STRAPPING NATIONAL ORDERS
TRANSPLANT. SELLING AND IT
ACTUALLY BURNING IT FOR ENERGY.
ABOUT WHY THIS. ISN'T COUNT
WILL DRAW FROM A SOLID AS AND-
UNDER THE OUR PS AND WHY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS REPEATEDLY.
TOUTED AS A TEMP TO CHANGE THAT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU MARK THANKS. CAN AFTERNOON
MY DEALER FOR CAL RELIEF WANT
TO THE CAN FOR THIS. I GIGI AND
IN WITH SOME EMPHASIS ON OUT RE
AS A CALL EFFECTIVE CARBON SINK
WE WANT TO FOCUS OUR COMMENTS
THREE FOR WE ARE JUST TO SEE
THE EXCLUSION UP URBAN FORCES
AS A G. G. RID. ELEMENT IN THE
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE REPORTS
SALLY THE REPORT GLOSSES OVER
THE TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AVOIDED THROUGH
URBAN FORESTRY AS DETERMINED BY
THE CALIFORNIA FOR IS CALLED
CARBON PLAN AS YOU MAY KNOW
THESE REDUCTIONS ARE. OCCURRING
IN SOME OF THE MOST DENSELY
POPULATED AND URBAN UNDERSERVED
AREAS IN THE STATE USING
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE'S. ALL
QUICKLY CAN. THAT TWENTY FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION TONS OF CO
TWO PER YEAR CAN BE CAPTURED
THROUGH. CALIFORNIA'S
NETWORKING LANDS URBAN FORCES
CAN WOOD AT 10% TO THAT FIGURE-
CONSEQUENTLY WE WANT WITH LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE. TO
CONSIDER AN ADDITIONAL HEARING
TO TAKE. TO TAKING A DIVE INTO
NOT TO WORKING LANCE AS DEFINED
IN THE PUBLIC RESOURCE CODE. TO
INCLUDE URBAN FOR SHARING
GREENING AND OTHER RESOURCES
AND AS IT RELATES TO THIS
ISSUE. A SECOND DESPITE THE
FACT THAT NATURAL RESOURCES ARE
LONG TERM COST EFFECTIVE GIGI
REDUCTION MECHANISMS.
INVESTMENTS TO ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS ARE MINIMAL AT BEST- FOR
EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
GIGI ALLOCATION PLAN FOR THE
YEAR AND THE LAST. I CONTAINS
FOR FORESTRY URBAN GREEN AND
WETLANDS OF THERE FOR THE
LATEST LEGISLATURE MáS. BE THE
LEADER NEEDS TO IF WE WANT TO
CONTINUE INVESTMENTS INTO AND
NATURAL RESOURCES AND THEN
FINALLY WE WANT TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF INTEGRATING
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY- WHEN IT COMES TO YOU
CAN. CREATE IN THE PATHWAY TO
ACHIEVING OUR GOALS- AS
ADVOCATES AND GRANT
ADMINISTRATORS- CALIFORNIA
RELIEVE RECOGNIZE THE
TREMENDOUS NEED TO HAVE
AUTHENTIC. RECOGNITION
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE EBAY
COMMUNITY SO YEAH. AND THANK
YOU AGAIN. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BILL MCGAVIN WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR BUT YOU'RE ALL
GOING TO BE VOTING ON THE
BUDGET SO I WANT TO STRESS THE
POINT THAT CHAIR GARCIA MADE
EARLIER THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD ACTUALLY CUT
FUNDING FROM THE CURRENT YEAR
FOR BOTH COMMUNITY OUR
PROTECTION AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND IN FACT WE
NEED FOR THOSE NUMBERS TO BE
GOING UP. CHAIR BECAUSE IN HER
TEAM SAID THE US REGULATORY
STAY IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY FOR
CLEANING UP OUR ENGINES WE NEED
TO COMPLEMENT THOSE REGULATORY
STANDARDS WITH INVESTMENT. BOTH
TO ADVANCE THE TECHNOLOGIES TO
EVEN CLEANER ENGINES AND ALSO
TO HASTEN THE TURNOVER FROM THE
OLD DIRTY VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT TO THE NEW MUCH
CLEANER ZERO MISSION AND NEAR
ZERO MISSION. TECHNOLOGIES SO
FOR THAT WE DO NEED FUNDING.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE IT ON A
CONSISTENT SUSTAIN BASIS NOT.
ANGEL IN GOING UP AND DOWN YEAR
TO YEAR SO I KNOW EVERYBODY
WANTS MONEY AND THE BUDGET IS
TIGHT BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT WE'RE EMISSIONS ARE
GOING UP. IT'S IN
TRANSPORTATION WHERE MOST OF
THE EMISSIONS ARE COMING FROM
IT'S IN TRANSPORTATION SO WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THAT ALL WHEN
IT COMES TO INVESTING THE FUNDS
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBER THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAUL MESA PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST- I WANT TO HONE IN
ON. THE NETWORKING LANDS PART
OF THE CONVERSATION
PARTICULARLY SOMETHING- THE
DIALOGUE THAT VICE CHAIR STERN
AND TERRY NICHOLS WERE HAVING
ABOUT THE- IMPORTANCE OF
NETWORKING LANDS THE INCREASING
EMISSIONS THERE AT A LARGE
CHUNK OF THE MISSIONS THAT ARE
NOT REFLECTED IN THE INVENTORY
WE TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME. AND
THE FACT THAT IT'S THE CHEAPEST
PLACE WHERE WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE NEGATIVE REDUCTIONS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE INFORMATION
PRESENTED TODAY. IT'S REALLY IN
ALL OF THE ABOVE- APPROACH DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN WITHOUT TO
WORKING LANDS AND THEN BIOMASS
AND THEN THE MORE EXPENSIVE
OPTIONS AS WE- MOVE ACROSS THE
CHART. WE NEED TO BE DOING
EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN IN THAT'LL
WORKING LANDS. WE HAVE A
MASSIVE DISCONNECT WITH THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE THERE AND
THE AND PASS BUDGETS. AND HOW
WE'RE ACTUALLY PLAYING- FUNDS
ON THE GROUND IT'S ALSO GOING
ON TO SENATOR ALLEN AS WELL AS
THE CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. BUT A CLIMATE
BOND YOU KNOW WILL BE BETTER
FOR AN ON STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING BUT THE INFUSION BE
REALLY HELPFUL. AND WE ALSO
NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO APPROACH
THESE CHALLENGES IN A MORE.
AMBITIOUS WAY WERE REALLY
WORKING ACROSS LANCE AND CAME
BACK INTO MORE REASON.
CONDITION THAT SEQUESTERING
CARBON A MORE STABLE WAY.
RATHER THAN A ONE OFF PROJECT
WE'VE BEEN DOING SO FAR SO.
I'LL SEE YOU WITH THAT TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI MY NAME
IS JAN WARREN I'M WITH THE
INTERFAITH CLIMATE ACTION
NETWORK A CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND WE HAVE FOUR EFINERIES AN
ARC. COMMUNITY OF. IN A
DECEMBER THE FIFTH I WAS IN
OAKLAND ATTENDING A CAR MEETING
AND WE WERE APPRECIATED THEM
COMING OUT LOCALLY. TO AWARD
THE WEST OAKLAND COMMUNITY
EMISSION REDUCTION PLANS PARTY
AB SIX SEVENTEEN. LOT OF GOOD
TURN OUT APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS- ABOUT- PIONEERING
COMMUNITIES FROM. MERRY BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT TWENTY
YEARS. AND IT'S BEEN TWO AND A
HALF YEARS SINCE THIS BILL WAS
PASSED AND WE'RE STILL LOOKING
FOR A- JUST. A LITTLE BIT OF
CLEANER AIR. I HEARD A LOT OF
PRAISE FOR THE FOR THE PROJECT
THAT DAY BUT DESPITE THE
WONDERFUL. REPORT IT WAS A PLAN
THAT WAS APPROVED. AND THAT.
PLAN NEEDS MONEY HAND US AS
SEVERAL OF SAID IT'S BEEN CUT.
AND THIS IS FOR A COMMUNITY
THAT'S READY TO GOAL AND WE'VE
GOT A LOT OF OTHERS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE'S NO
MONEY FOR. A THEY'RE JUST
WAITING SO WE NEED THIS THE TO
GO BACK TO THE GOVERNOR AND-
REALLY- PLEAD FOR. MONEY FOR
THESE FOLKS WERE AT. I JUST SAW
THE WONDERFUL- RIVERSIDE THE-
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CARB
FACILITY ONLINE AND THAT'S
GREAT BUT- THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
THEY DON'T WE DON'T GET MUCH
BUT WE NEED THAT EVERY. BIT WE
GET. I THANK THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS ABOUT SB SIX SEVENTEEN
WAS ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS I
CAME TODAY. TO SUPPORT TO THE
RESTORATION INCREASE OF FUNDING.
A I ALSO WORK SUPPORT TO YOU
YOU LOOKING AT THE CAP AND
TRADE- SO HER THREE COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THAT- ANXIOUS TO-
PARTICIPATE AND CONNECT WITH
YOU ALL. BECAUSE THAT'S THE
REASON WE GOT AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IT DIDN'T GET THE CAPS ON THE
REFINERIES WITH- GHGS. AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. HI DAVID WEISS CAUGHT
FROM NEXT IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU CHARTER SEE- AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS HEARING
THIS IS- IMPORTANT VENUE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU MAKING AVAILABLE
TO US AND HAVING THIS
INFORMATIVE PRESENTATIONS. I'D
LIKE TO SO SEE MY COMMENTS WITH
THE REMARKS FROM THE GOVERNOR
EARLIER ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADDRESSING TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS- WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO DO MORE IT'S WHERE THE IT'S
WHERE THE POLLUTION IS IT'S
GOING UP HI AND IT'S BEING CUT
IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET I THINK
WE NEED TO RESTORE THAT AND GO
FURTHER- I ALSO WANT TO.
EMPHASIZE SOMETHING THAT YOUR
NICKEL SAID EARLIER. THAT I
THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF TOOLS
THAT WE CAN DRAW MORE UPON- IN
OUR STATE REGULATORY AND
BUDGETARY AUTHORITY. TO HELP-
DRIVE THESE TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS DOWN. FOR EXAMPLE THE
CAP AND TRADE DISCRETIONARY
FUND IS A LITTLE BIT UNDER
BILLION DOLLARS THE CDC ANNUAL
BUDGET IS ABOUT TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS- AND ARGUABLY HAS MORE
IMPACT ON OUR GHG EMISSIONS
STATEWIDE- THIS IS TRUE ACROSS
THE BOARD I THINK- IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO LOOK. AT WHAT ALL
THE AGENCIES ARE DOING AND HOW-
THE RULE MAKINGS AND SPENDING-PRIORITIES CAN BE BROUGHT IN
LINE. WITH THE TWENTY FORTY
FIVE CARBON TARGET- COME
NEUTRALITY TARGET. I COULD JUST
ANOTHER MY I WANT TO THANK THE
NATIONAL- NATIONAL LABS FOR THE
REPORT. AND REINFORCE- COMMENTS
THAT CHARITY A MADE- THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DISTINGUISH
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS FROM THE
EMISSIONS INVENTORY- SO THAT IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT SAY A PROJECT
THAT USES- CARBON SEQUESTRATION
FOR THE PURPOSES OF A LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD COMPLIANCE
ARE THOSE TONS OF ALREADY BEEN
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE CONTENTS
CONTEXT OF THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD THOSE WOULD NOT BE
ADDITIONAL NEGATIVE TONS AND-
SIMILARLY WITH OTHER. PROGRAMS
WHERE THERE'S OVERLAPPING
EITHER INCENTIVES OR COMPLIANCE
OBLIGATIONS IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO KEEP. ADDITIONAL NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS COMPLETELY SEPARATE
FROM OTHER COMPLIANCE BASED
TOOLS FOR THE EXISTING
EMISSIONS INVENTORY AND
REDUCTION PROGRAMS I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANKS SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON I FIRST ONE CAN ECHO
WHAT ON THE PREVIOUS COMMENTER
SAID AROUND CAN SEQUESTER OR
LOOKING AT FOR NEGATIVE AND
OTHER COMPLIANCE MECHANISMS
KEEPING THOSE SEPARATE AND AN
ADDITIVE I'M IN ALL OF OUR
CLIENT PROGRAMS A COUPLE THINGS
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKINGWITH
MANY OF YOU ON CLIMATE BOND
AND- G. G. R. F. AND CLAMOR
RESILIENCE LOAN FUND-
NEGOTIATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
OVER THE PAST FOUR MONTHS AND
WANT TO FOCUS A BIT ON- TODAY'S
PRESENTATION I JUST. WANNA MAKE
REINFORCE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS
ON IMPACTS I THINK AS WE LOOK
AT HOW WE'RE DEVELOPING
TECHNOLOGIES AND EXPANDING
EXISTING TECHNOLOGIES WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN FOR THE COMMUNITIES
NEARBY WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR
WASTE FACILITIES NEED IT WOULD
THAT THE COMMUNITIES NEAR.
WASTE HAPPY MAKE SURE THAT
BURDENS ARE EQUITABLY AND AS
WELL AS BENEFITS AND SIMILARLY
FOR REGION'S I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT OUR-
CLIMBING SORRY DEVELOPMENT
GOALS IN A GOALS IN UNITS. SO
WHAT DO WE DO ON OUR ON.
NEGATIVE COMMENT NEW. TO OLD
EXT ECONOMIC P. IN AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN LEFT FINALLY I JUST
WANNA GIVE A THAT THE PROBE
THAT IS PRESENT TODAY IN THE
HORNS OF IN. COMMUNITY FEEL AND
COMMUNITY AND- IN PROGRAM TO
THAT AND DELIVERY AND THAT'S
WHERE E SEE THE BIGGEST
SUCCESS THIS. THANKS SO MUCH. I
AM AS A MINTON WITH VOICE FOR
PRAGUE WHERE BAY LEADER AND BY.
UNDER AND PLANTAR. AND WE WERE
TO PROTECT AGAINST CLAY CHANGE
I JUST WANT TO THANK THAT CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THIS. BECAUSE
ALL OF YOU DO ADMIRABLE IN THIS
ARENA. AND WE JUST WANT TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND SAY
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
BUDGET PLEASE. AND INVEST MORE
IN AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
OBVIOUSLY. I IT'S A PROVEN
STRATEGY TO REDUCE CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT WE SEE IT GOING DOWN
IN THE BUDGET LAST YEAR AND
THIS YEAR AS WELL. THINK AGAIN
AND- WE APPRECIATE THIS HEARING
TODAY. CHAU SENATOR. MY NAME IS
GARY HUGHES AND I WORK ITH A
SMALL INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION CALLED BIO FEEL
WATCH. AND I'M REALLY GLAD TO
BE HERE TODAY- THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE CHAIR GARCIA FOR
BRINGING THIS TOGETHER. THERE'S
A LOT TO UNPACK HERE THERE'S
ACTUALLY A GREAT DEAL OF
INFORMATION THAT COULD BE
BROKEN DOWN TO LIKE TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF. THE FIRST THING
IS THERE'S A LOT OF A RONI
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT FORCE
MANAGEMENT BEING BANDIED ABOUT
HERE- THERE'S A- HIGH DEGREE OF
AMNESIA. FORGETTING WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO CALIFORNIA'S
FOREST'S. SEEMS TO BE A TOTAL
ABSENCE TO REMEMBER IN THE PULP
MILLS FOR INSTANCE THAT WERE ON
HUMBOLDT BAY THAT I GREW UP
WITH. AND THE DEVASTATION THAT
OCCURRED IN THE FORCE IN THE
STATE. SO ARE FOR. HAVE BEEN
AND CANNOT CONTINUE TO BE TREAT.
AS FEEDSTOCK. FOREST DEBRIS
MATTERS IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IF
IT IS THAT WE WANT TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR FORCES THAT THEY SERVE
US IN RESPONDING THE CLIMATE
CRISIS WE NEED TO STORED OUR
FORCE SO FOR INSTANCE THE FACT
THAT RAINBOW RIDGE GOT LOGGED
LAST SUMMER. AND RAINBOW RIDGE
OF COURSE PROPERTY THAT BELONGS
TO ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
HUMBLED REDWOOD COMPANY. THIS
HAS TO BE ADDRESSED. SO THAT
THERE WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
FORCE. BUT I DO WANT TO BRING
UP ANOTHER TOPIC THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT'S IN MY ROLE
THE BIO FEEL WATCH I
PARTICIPATE IN AN INTERNATIONAL
COALITION CALLED HANDS OFF
MOTHER EARTH. THERE'S A NUMBER
OF GROUPS AND THE GLOBAL SOUTH-
THE CLIMATE JUSTICE ALLIANCE
FROM HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
IS INVOLVED. WE'RE WORKING WITH.
FROM ALL AROUND THE WORLD ON
THIS. AND WHAT HASN'T BEEN
MENTIONED HERE BASICALLY IS A
GREAT DEAL OF WHAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED TODAY IS GEO
ENGINEERING. DIRECT AIR CAPTURE
IS SPECIFICALLY A GEO
ENGINEERING TECHNIQUE BIO
ENERGY WITH CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION BETTER KNOWN AS
BACKS. IS GEO ENGINEERING. AND
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO SAY
THAT TODAY AND IT'S I THINK
IT'S REALLY SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING AT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AS WELL IT
HAPPENED AT A NUMBER OF THE
CARBON NEUTRALITY WORKSHOPS
LAST YEAR. A THESE REFERENCES
THESE EUPHEMISMS TO ARTIFICIAL
SEQUESTRATION OF MECHANICAL
SEQUESTRATION AND DIRECT. IT'S
LIKE THESE MACHINES THAT WANNA
BE INVENT THIS IS GEO
ENGINEERING AND SO WE NEED TO
BE TRANSPARENT AND SPEAK AND
LET THE PUBLIC KNOW THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
ENTERTAINING THE IDEA. OF
EMBARKING UPON GEO IN NEARING.
SO I BELIEVE. YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT'S RISK. OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO ENSURE THAT WERE
BEING FULLY TRANSPARENT. WITH
THE PUBLIC- THERE'S A LOT OF
DANGERS WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES- ALONG WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR INSTANCE THE
CREATION OF SALE OF CELLULOSIC
BIO FUELS WOULD BE THE
SYNTHETIC BIOLOGY THAT'S
REQUIRED TO COULD BE EVEN IN
GENETIC LEE MODIFY TREES. OR
ALSO WITH THE MICRO ORGANISMS
THAT ARE REQUIRED SO THESE
THESE ARE ALL REALLY IMPORTANT
TOPICS THAT CAN GET TOUCH UP
TODAY SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS YOU MOVE FOR TALKING
ABOUT. NEGATIVE EMISSIONS WHICH
ARE REALLY NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE'RE
TRANSPARENT AMONGST OURSELVES
AND WITH THE PUBLIC THE
CALIFORNIA IS NOW ENDEAVORING
TO. EXPLORE GEO ENGINEERING AS
A RESPONSE TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. GET AFTER MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY FOR ME THEM PRIOR WIKI
WITH FOR BY. DIVERSITY I
REALIZE WE ARE ALL A FIVE SO I
BE VERY SHORT. A LOT OF VERY
INTERESTING TOPIC TODAY
OBVIOUSLY THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY OUR
MEMBERS OUR ALLIES I'M SEE A
LOT OF BENEFITS. TO CABIN
NEGATIVE APPROACH AS WE WANT TO
SEE- THIS WITH LOVE TO WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE SEE THIS
COMMITTEE TO START TACKLING
THOSE INDIVIDUAL PIZZAS. MANY
OF THEM HAVE. BENEFITS
POTENTIAL BENEFITS FOR
COMMUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUAL
HOMES AND FOR OUR NATURAL ON
WORKING LANDS THE ALL THAT HAVE
THEN ADDITIONAL CO BENEFITS FOR
THINGS LIKE WILDLIFE WATER
ETCETERA. MANY OF THOSE ARE NO
REGRETS IN THAT WE SEE THOSE BY
HAVE AND IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE
WAYS THAT- THAT THE PLANTING
MORE TREES ON OUR ON OUR
STREETS ARE NOT GOOD AND ALL OF
THE BENEFITS OF SPRING ARE
GOING TO HAVE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES THAT HAVE TO- BE
CONSIDERED. IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE CARBON
IMPACT IMPACTS ARE. FORREST
SOURCED WOODY BIOMASS IS NOT
ONE OF THOSE NO REGRETS-
ISSUES. FOR SERVICE WITH THE
BIOMASS CARBON IMPLICATIONS ARE
VERY PROJECT SPECIFIC SITE
SPECIFIC AND PROCESS SPECIFIC.
AND SO. THOSE A SUMP BE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO APPLY AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL TO COME UP WITH SOME OF
THESE OVER ARCHING IDEAS OVER
ARCHING- CONCEPTS OF THE OF THE
GENERAL SCALE. ARE NOT GOING TO
NECESSARILY APPLY AT THE
INDIVIDUAL PROJECT OF AND OF
COURSE IT'S AT THE INDIVIDUAL
PROJECT LEVEL THAT YOU HAVE THE
ACTUAL CARBON IMPACTS SO WE
LOOK FOR TO MANY HERE ON MANY
OF THESE ISSUES AND- I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM US IN
PARTICULAR ON THE FOREST WOODY
BIOMASS COMPONENT. THANK YOU.
HELLO LAURIN COLUMN WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT- WE ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY BRENDA
ACCUSE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. ALSO WE ALSO BELIEVE
IT IS TIME TO DISCUSS NEGATIVE
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES WHILE THE
STATE CONTINUES TO PUSH FOR
REAL CARBON. PRODUCTION
REDUCTIONS. THERE'S A STRONG
POTENTIAL TO CONTINUE TO
SEQUESTER AND ENHANCE
SEQUESTRATION OF CARBON IN
NATURAL ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE
WAYS. THIS WOULD INCLUDE
EXPANDING NATURAL SINGS BY
PLANTING TREES OR CULTIVATING
AN ENCOURAGING HEALTHY SOILS
SIX AFTER. MY COMMENTS YOUR
GENERAL ABOUT SOME CONCERNS WE
HAVE WITH A COUPLE OF
TECHNOLOGIES MENTIONED IN THE
CARBON I GET A REPORT. FIRST
WITH THE REPORT IS FAR TOO
GENEROUS TO THE BY MASS
INCINERATION INDUSTRY. TODAY
THE EXISTING INDUSTRIES NET
EMITTER OF CARBON AS WELL AS A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION INCLUDING IN SOME. IN
SOME OF THE MOST POLLUTED
PLACES IN THE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY BIOMASS
GASIFICATION TECHNOLOGY IS
BARELY DEVELOPED IS NOT I CAN
MAKE ALL THE- ALTHOUGH A LOWER.
THAN CONVENTIONAL BYPASS AND
CENTER. IT WILL BE A- FOR THE
STATE PURSUE A QUE. OR MORE.
ONE PULL ALL. EXIST FOR
HANDLING FORCED WASTE. WE HAVE
PRODUCED A REPORT AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE ABOUT SOME POSSIBLE
ALTERNATIVES TO INCINERATION
AND URGE YOU TO REVIEW THAT.
SECOND IF THE STATE MOVES IN
THE DIRECTION OF CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE THAT REQUIRE
INJECTION AS PROMOTED IN THE
REPORT WE NEED TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T
JUST BECOME AN OFFSET. TO ALLOW
OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS IN THE
STATE TO CONTINUE BUSINESS AS
USUAL. WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT CARBON INJECTION IS
NOT LINKED TO SEISMIC EVENTS
AND WE NEED TO INJURE ENSURE
THE ANY INJECTION OR AIR
CAPTURE DOES NOT RELY UPON OR
EXPAND THE USE. OF GAS FIRED
ELECTRICITY PLANTS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS TO FIND
REAL SOLUTIONS THAT PROTECT
COMMUNITIES PRESERVE NATURAL
LANDS. AND STOP OR USE OR
RELIANCE POLLUTING FUELS CAME.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND YOUR SPEAKERS MY
NAME'S VERONICA PART ON BEHALF
OF THE NORTHERN DISTRICT OF THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL. WE ARE A MEMBER OF THE
ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MS LEVIN-
AT THE OUTSET OF THIS
CONVERSATION BUT I DO WANT TO.
THANK THE SPEAKERS FOR
ADDRESSING SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THIS IS A HUGE LEFT. FOR
CALIFORNIA NEAR TRIPLING OF OUR
CURRENT ORGANICS MANAGEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE MEMBERS
THAT I REPRESENT- A COLLECTIVE
PROCESS RECYCLING. MOVE THAT
MATERIAL- TO RECYCLE CONTENT
MARKETS AND FOR RECYCLING IN-
COMPOST AND SOIL AMENDMENT SO
THIS IS. SUCH AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU. FOR HAVING A CONVERSATION
IN PARTICULAR AROUND THE WOODY
BIOMASS. FEED STOCK IT'S A
PARTICULAR FEEDSTOCK THAT'S
HIGHS SO YOU LOST IT BEATS
STOCK- LANDS TO CERTAIN
APPLICATIONS. LOS SHOULD YOU
KNOW WAS REALLY WELL WITH THAT
OF FOOD WASTE AND AN AND WHAT
GREEN BUT THE HIGH SO YOU LASIK
WOULD WAYS HAVE POTENTIAL HERE
AND SOBRE IT. THE CON. AND THE
FOR TO FURTHER HERE THANK YOU.
I NICHOLS HAD HONOR A JUST MY
TODAY. I WANT TO THANK YOU IS
ALL THE CHAIR OF A R. B. AS
WELL AS LARA SLIM LABS REALLY.
HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPORTANCE OF
NEGATIVE MISSIONS. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- THE UN'S IPCC SAID
ALL PATHWAYS THE LIMIT GLOBAL
WARMING TO ONE POINT FIVE
DEGREES CELSIUS WITH LIMITED OR
NO OVERSHOOT PROJECT THE USE OF
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL. IF YOU
LOOK AT THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES THEY CAME OUT WITH A
REPORT LAST YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN SAY THEY SAY BY TWENTY
FIFTY WE NEED TO BE REMOVING
TEN GIGA TONS. OF CO TWO THAT
DOUBLES TO TWENTY BY THE END OF
THE CENTURY. WHAT WHAT I THINK
THE MAIN TAKEAWAY TAKE FROM
THESE PRESENTATIONS WE NEED TO
BE THINKING NEGATIVE MISSIONS
AS A NEW PILLAR OF OUR APPROACH
TO COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
RICHARD. TWENTY THIRTEEN TWENTY
FORTY FIVE CALLS. THANK YOU.
GET A- MICHAEL BOCA OUR OWN. OF
WESCO ADVISE FOR THE EVER CALL
ENERGY. ASSOCIATE I THINK IT'S
A GOOD MEMBERS NOW WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE STATE'S DAIRY
INDUSTRY. I LOOK FORWARD TO
READING OFF THE WHOLE REPORT
BUT- THE DAIRY INDUSTRY IS
DOING EXACTLY WHAT WAS
DESCRIBED OR TAKING. DURING THE
NEWER AND TURNING IT INTO LOW
CARBON NEGATIVE CARBON
TRANSPORTATION FEELING
CALIFORNIA TODAY. FOR MAKING
COMPRESS RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
FOR HEAVY DUTY FREIGHT AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO EVOLVE
THAT. WE RECOGNIZE THAT'S
PROBABLY A THE- A LIMITED TIME
BUT WE'RE READY WORKING TOWARDS
PRODUCING ELECTRICITY FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE
TRANSPORTATION. TO PROJECTS
WERE JUST FUNDED BY CDFA LAST
YEAR USING FEEL CELLS TO
PRODUCE CLEAN ELECTRICITY. FOR
EVEY CHARGING STATIONS IN THE
STATE- THERE'S ANOTHER PERIL
HERE AND THE DAIRY INDUSTRY'S
PART OF THAT CIRCULAR ECONOMY-
WHEN YOU LOOK CLOSELY AT THE
DURING THIS. INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA COWS ARE GREAT
RECYCLERS OVER 40% OF THE FEED.
WE USE IN THE CALIFORNIA THEIR
INDUSTRY TODAY. COMES FROM
OTHER AGRICULTURAL BYPRODUCTS
ALMOND HOLES ARE A GREAT
EXAMPLE WE EAT THE NUTS. THE
SHELLS CAN GO FOR BIOMASS THE
HOLES ARE GREAT CATTLE FEED.
AND ALLOW US TO REDUCE OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT SIGNIFICANTLY-
UC DAVIS IS WORKING ON A-
ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT- FOR
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'LL BE OUT THE
NEXT WEEK OR SO IT'S CURRENTLY
BEING PUBLISHED IN SO WE'LL SEE
THAT VERY SOON COMING FORWARD.
LAST ONE OF MY- A. THE STANDARD
PROGRAM AND I THINK THE CAN
SHOULD SET SOME TIME ON THAT.
WE ARE INCREASING CA. ABOUT ALL
CA PRO BECAUSE WE SEE A LOT OF
OUR- STILL. GOING OUT TO STAY
OUT OF STATE PRIDE. IN OF THESE
PROJECTS INCLUDING SOME VERY
PROJECTS AND OTHER STATES
INDIANA NEW YORK AND ELSEWHERE.
OR ARE BEING PROVIDED EL CFS
CREDITS EVEN THOUGH THERE IS NO
ADDITIONAL METHANE REDUCTION
OCCURRING FROM THOSE PROJECTS
THESE WERE EXISTING PROJECTS.
THEY WERE PRODUCING ELECTRICITY
OR FEELS FOR LOCAL. COMMUNITIES
AND NOW THEY'RE PRODUCING
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND GETTING A
WINDFALL A HUGE WINDFALL FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE'RE GETTING NO BENEFIT FOR
THOSE DOLLARS AND CLEARLY THE
COSTS OF GETTING WERE
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO GO OR GOING
TO BECOME MORE EXPENSIVE.
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP
OUR DOLLARS LOCAL WE'RE NOT
ONLY GET THE METHANE PRODUCTION
HERE IN THE STATE WHICH WE NEED
FOR SHORT LIVED I'M BLOOM
PROGRAMS WE GET THE JOBS HERE.
WE GET THE OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS HERE THAT MANY OF
THESE PROJECTS PROVIDE. ONLY
SEND THOSE DOLLARS OUT OF STATE
WE GET NONE OF THAT IN MAY BE
NO ADDITIONAL ALLEY THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. HI
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR I
CHECKS WITH ENERGY. AND TO
POINTS THE THANKS FOR HAVING
THIS IN. FORM THIS MERGING TO
OF NAY BUT MISSION TECHNOLOGY
AND FOR YOUR HELL FRAME. THAT
WE NEED TO GO ABSOLUTELY
FURTHER AND FASTER ON OUR
MITIGATION STRATEGIES BUT THERE
IS A ROLE TO LOOK FOR IN
NEGATIVE EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES
AND HOW WE CAN DO THAT. SAFELY
BUT I WANT TO INVITE PERHAPS
FURTHER PARTICIPATION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE HEARD. FROM
OUR FORMER GOVERNOR ON AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR CARBON
NEUTRALITY BUT WE HAVEN'T YET
HEARD FROM. THE LEGISLATURE ON
HOW THEY CONCEIVE OF THAT
TARGET I THINK IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO HAVE CERTAINLY THAT
THAT'S DIRECTIONAL GOING. AND
AS A PLACE TO PROVIDE SOME
DIRECTION TO ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS AOUT HOW THAT IT
COUNTY SHOULD BE DONE. AND TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT USING
COVERAGE HOWDY AS AN EXCUSE TO
LET OFFERED THE FOOT OFF THE
GAS ON TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY.
WHERE WE KNOW WHAT WE KNOW WE
NEED TO MAKE PROGRESS JUST LAST
YEAR. NEW YORK STATE PASSED A
BILL WHICH SET- THE NET ZERO.
TARGET MID CENTURY BUT CLEAR
585% OF THE REDUCTIONS WOULD BE
COMING FROM. THE FOSSEL
MISSIONS ESSENTIALLY WHICH IS
HOW IT CALIFORNIA'S DOING THAT
ACCOUNTING SO. DON'T LIKE NEW
YORK JUMPING AHEAD OF US ON
ANYTHING RELATED TO CLIMATE-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. HEAR
SOMETHING FROM YOU GUYS SOON.
AND SECOND AND YOU KNOW GOALS
ARE IMPORTANT WE NEED TO KEEP
SETTING GOALS BUT THE FOLLOW
THROUGH IS REALLY KEY SO I
THINK YOU'VE HEARD TODAY THAT.
BEFORE PROPOSING BUT IT'S- THAT
ARE CUTTING EMISSIONS ARE
CUTTING FUNDING FOR KIßM THE
REST. YOU KNOW WE THE FORTY.
FOUR AND ALL. YOUR. TERRORIST
ABOUT. THE ROLE OF CAP AND
TRADE THE SCOPING PLAN WITH IS
K. REALLY CALL THE GAP. AND I
THINK WE ARE THAT THAT CRY.
WHERE AGREE THAT THE CURRENT.
NOT YOU KNOW WHAT DOES NOT. TO
THAT NEED DAHLE. I THINK. OF
REMOTE VILLAGES SAY THAT THEY
HAVE AN EQUAL ROLE TO PLAY HERE
AND THAT. WE CAN HAVE A MY
HIGHER ON CARBON THAT'S NOT
GONNA OVER ON THE COORDINATION
CHALLENGES. PERMITTING IS. YOU
KNOW WE CAN UPS ON AROUND AND
IS WAS OTHER. WE KNOW OUR BE
ABLE TO. ALSO AND WE. THANK YOU
CHAIR FOR HOSTING THIS MEETING
TODAY AND INFORMATIVE
PRESENTATIONS. UP FOR QUICK
POINTS SO AT THE END OF A LONG
DAY AND IN A DARK TIMES IS
SENATOR STERN MENTIONED I DON'T
WANNA LOSE. SIGHT OF THE NUMBER
AND TAKE AWAY FROM MISTER
PARADIS IS- REPORT WHICH IS
THAT WE CAN DO IT WE CAN CHIEF
CARNAGE JOLLITY WE HAVE OPTIONS.
TWO OF THOSE OPTIONS OTHER
REPORT I WISH WE WOULD'VE SEEN
TABLE E. S. FIVE- WHICH LAYS
OUT THE COST EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE SOLUTIONS OF THEM NATURAL
WORKING LAND SOLUTIONS ARE- THE
LOWEST COST. THEY'RE ALSO
READILY DEPLOYABLE AND THEY
HAVE THE MOST CO BENEFITS IN
TERMS OF- BENEFITS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FOOD SECURITY. WATER
RESILIENCE AND OTHER ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT- THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF THOSE CO BENEFITS
AREN'T ACCOUNTED FOR THAT
REPORT AND OFTEN ARE OVERLOOKED
IN THE WAY WE ACCOUNT FOR ON.
THESE INVESTMENTS. THE THIRD I
WANT TO LINE US WITH THE-
COMMENTS FROM OUR EASY
COMMUNITIES AND COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IN SAYING THAT ARE
LIMITED PUBLIC RESOURCES
THROUGH THE BOND IN THE BUDGET-
MUST BE USED TO SUPPORT A JUST
TRANSITION FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. A AND HAVE THE LEAST
RESOURCES ACCESS TO FINANCE TO
DAFT SO IN AGRICULTURE WHERE I
WORK- THOSE ARE SMALL AND MID
SCALE FAMILY FARMS. A SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
FARMERS OF COLOR AND
FARMWORKERS. AND LASTLY- WE
GREET THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THAT THESE AND OTHER
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. TO
ENSURE EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION
MEANING FULL SCALE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE CARBON
NEUTRALITY- MEASURES MUST
INCLUDE THOSE COMMUNITIES AT
THE OUTSET. I IN THEIR DESIGN
AND CERTAINLY THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION SO THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TO OUR PRESENTERS
TODAY THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME I DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS- WE WILL BE HAVING.
FOLLOW UP HEARING FROM SOME OF
THESE TOPICS AS AS WE LOOK AT
WE WANT TO GO- I WILL TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY I AM THE
CHAIR ON A COUPLE OF THINGS AS
WE TALK ABOUT. NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS A NATURAL- AND
WORKING LINES. AND THAT THAT WE
LOOK AT THE URBAN FORESTRY THAT
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE PRETTY NAY
TREE CANOPY NEXT TO THE FREEWAY
SO THAT TOOK MY DISTRICT. ON
AND SO FORTH AND SAYS WELL AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE LARGE
SKILLS THAT WE CAN GO
TRADITIONALLY IN OUR FOREST.
THAT WITH A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT TO THE BUT WE ALSO THINK
ABOUT URBAN OPPORTUNITIES AND
THAT WE ARE DOING BOTH. LOCAL
SMALL AND- LARA SCALE PROJECTS.
THERE AND AS WE TALK ABOUT COOL
BENEFITS AROUND CLEAN AIR
SPECIFICALLY THAT WE ARE
INTENTIONAL WITH THAT AND SO
ONE OF THE TOOLS OF THE BE SIX
SEVENTEEN AND- AS WE WERE
REMINDED WE ONLY HAVE THE PLANS
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN IMPLEMENTED
THEM YET AND SO DOLLARS
TEMPERAMENTAL. CURRENT PLANS
WITHIN YOU PLANS THAT ARE
COMING OUT DOWN THERE BUT AS WE
TRY TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
JUSTICE. FOR ALL OUT THERE AND
I THINK AS WE- LOOK AT THE
REALITY THAT WE THOUGHT WE HAD
A SENTRY TO GET TO WHERE WE'RE
AT ACTUALLY TODAY- THAT WE-
REVISIT EVERYTHING AND- IF-
THIS I MEAN WE NEED TO GET RID
US OF HOW DO WE STRENGTHEN WHAT
WE ALREADY HAVE AND HOW DO WE
SUPPLEMENTAL IT. WITH OTHER
THINGS SINCE I THINK WE NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT OUR- ALL OF OUR
TOOLS. AS WE LOOK AT COST
EFFECTIVENESS NOT JUST LOOKING
AT. THE DOLLAR BOTTOM LINE
PROFIT MARGINS TO COMPANIES
THAT WE LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
HEALTH. OF COMMUNITIES HEALTH
OF INDIVIDUALS AND- THE FUTURE
HEALTH OF OUR OF OUR EARTH AND
SO HAVING THAT ARE TO SEE
THERE. ALONG THE WAY I DO
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S WORK I
WANT TO THANK. MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER GARCIA FOR. HIS WORK TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL IS PASSED
THE THAT HAD. IS NO HAVE TELL
ME TO. AND REFLECT AT LEAST.
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE WORK WITH.
COLLEAGUES WE NEED TO DO MORE
ON. BUT I DO WANT TO THANK FOR
LEADERSHIP. ON AND IS THERE TO
LOT ON ON OUR GOALS HERE FOR.
JUST TRANSITION SO WITH THAT
WILL BRING THANK YOU.